learn all about react native in this
complete beginner's course from Emma
Williams she is a software engineer who
specializes in react native Emma will
teach you everything you need to know to
start developing cross-platform native
mobile apps using JavaScript app
downloads continue to increase year on
year creating some big Revenue
learning how to create mobile apps is
also a lot of fun
in this course I'll be introducing you
to react native and together we'll build
a weather application you're welcome to
just watch the video or follow along
the only prerequisite for the course is
that you have a text editor set up I'll
be using atom but you're welcome to use
whichever one you prefer before we go
any further if you're planning to follow
along with this tutorial I'm going to
start by showing you how to register for
an API key which will be needed for the
application it can take some time for
the API key to activate which is why I'm
suggesting starting by registering the
key now
the API key we'll use for the
application is called the open Weather
API and can be found here
so you'll need to start by registering
and then creating an API key
we will be using the five-day forecast
which is free and can be found here
we'll return back to this later in the
tutorial so what is react native
well react native is a framework which
was created by Facebook and was
initially released in 2015.
react native lets you create mobile apps
for IOS and Android by using JavaScript
in the land of mobile apps we have two
types of apps native and hybrid apps
when you create a mobile app you have
two choices
create a hybrid app or create a native
app when you create a native app you
write two separate applications one will
use Swift or objective c and is an app
for the iOS platform
the other uses kotlin or Java and is an
application for the Android platform
creating a native application gives you
opportunities for fantastic user
experiences but the trade-off is that it
means you need to do the work twice in
order to create one application once for
iOS and one for Android and often this
means you need two development teams the
alternative is to create a hybrid app so
hybrid apps have one code base and can
run on multiple platforms and examples
of these include Cordova and ionic so
you could have one code base and the app
can run on both IOS and Android
the benefit with hybrid apps is that you
don't need two code bases or knowledge
of multiple languages
the issue with a traditional hybrid app
though is that you're essentially
creating a web app that runs on a phone
so you have a container which renders
web views
a webview essentially vendors a website
inside of the application
when you do this the user experience is
restricted
so this is where react native comes in
whilst technically react native is a
hybrid platform because you only have
one code base the app renders using real
native UI components as opposed to
webviews react native takes our
JavaScript code and makes a bridge
between our app and our Target platform
so our components get rendered natively
without using web views and we can use
platform specific apis and components
consequently we have a more performant
app with a much better user experience
you're also able to extend the code and
create custom native components if
required so you might have heard of Expo
already but what is Expo
well Expo is an external platform which
makes our lives easier when we're
developing building and deploying react
native applications
it is not compulsory to use Expo but if
you're just getting started it is much
quicker
if you don't use Expo you have to go
through the various steps of installing
Android studio and xcode and then making
sure you have simulators and emulators
running when we use Expo we can just run
the app easily on our device by simply
scanning a QR code for this course we'll
be using Expo
so let's go ahead and get our
environment set up so firstly we need to
make sure we have a recent version of
node installed
next we need to go ahead and install the
XPO CLI which will help us to create our
project
to do this we just type npm install Dash
G because we want it installed globally
Expo CLI
now we need to navigate to the directory
where we would like to create our
project
and then we can just go ahead and create
it we do this by typing npx create Expo
app
weather app
now all we have left to do is to run the
project
so we change directories into where we
want the project to run by typing CD
weather app
and now we just type npm start
you can also type Expo start or yarn
start here if you have yarn installed
and that is your preferred package
manager
lastly we can Now preview the app on our
phones
you have to make sure your phone is on
the same internet connection as your
computer
then you can install the client for Expo
from the app store or the Google Play
Store
you can find this by searching for Expo
and the app is free
once this is installed you can scan the
QR code onto the camera if you're using
an iOS device or from the app if you're
using an Android device
at this point you should see the app
running
for the purposes of teaching this course
I'll be running the app on a simulator
so I'll briefly go ahead in the next
video and show you how to set this up
but feel free to skip this section if
you're happy to run the app on your own
device so now we've looked at setting up
a react native application using Expo
I'm going to show you how to set the app
up using the react native CLI
you don't need to watch this section or
do the setup if you're happy to run the
app using Expo on your own device but
I'm going to show you how to complete
the setup using this approach so you're
aware of it because as I mentioned
earlier if you want to build an
application using custom native code
then you need to use this approach
so we'll start by looking at iOS
for this you need to have a Mac if you
don't have a Mac you can still watch or
you can skip to the section where I set
up an application and then move on to
Android
so we'll start by following the
documentation on the react native
website
we need to make sure we have node and
Watchman installed
if you want to work with multiple
versions of node I highly suggest using
NVM and the setup for this can be found
here
for those of you who aren't familiar
with Watchman Watchman detects when the
source code has changed so it can
rebuild the bundle automatically next
you need to make sure you have the
correct version of Ruby installed
on your machine you can type Ruby dash
dash version to check which version you
have installed
if it doesn't match the version react
native uses we can find more information
about that here
and then you need to install this
version too
you can do this by using a ruby package
manager such as rvm
so now we're ready to install xcode and
we do this via the App Store
this will install the various tools and
simulators for us to run the application
this installation can take some time so
you may want to pause the video here and
let this download if you're following
along
so now we need to make sure we have
cocoapods installed if you have never
used poker pods it's a dependency
manager a little bit like npm but for
iOS
so now we have everything installed we
can go ahead and create the application
it's worth noting the warning provided
on the website which says if we have
previously installed the react native
CLI we should remove it to avoid
unexpected issues so we'll do that now
by typing npm uninstall Dash G react
native CLI
and at react native Community CLI
so now let's navigate to where we want
to create the project and we'll do this
by saying MPX react native init awesome
project
for those of you who are not familiar
MPX is part of the npm tool chain which
lets you run commands without installing
things globally
at this point our project should be set
up so we can navigate into it by typing
CD awesome project
and now we're ready to start the
application
we need to use two commands for this so
it's useful to have two separate windows
open in your terminal
First Command we use is MPX react native
start this command will start running
Metro which is the bundler that react
native uses
we could also run yarnstart here if you
prefer to use yarn as your package
manager or even npm run start
finally we're ready to start the
application and we do this by typing MPX
react native run iOS
now you should see the application
launch inside a simulator
as a side note if you're more
comfortable working with xcode you can
launch the application from there you
will need to open the XC workspace
ensure you're running Metro with react
native start and then you can manually
run a simulator
in the next section we'll move on to
launching the application via Android
in the last section we looked at running
the application using xcode and iOS
this time we'll look at running the
application with Android Studio
the first thing you'll need to do is to
make sure you have Android Studio
downloaded and installed
the link to download this can be found
here
once Android Studio is installed we need
to make sure we have an emulator set up
to do this we simply open Android Studio
and select configure
we then create our device
when you are running the application on
Android you need to make sure the
emulator is launched before you do
anything else
we can simply double click the device
here to launch it if you want to launch
the emulator from your command line you
type emulator Dash avd and then type the
name
so now we can close Android studio and
type npx react native run Android and we
should see our application launch in the
emulator
if you prefer to use your own device
here you can simply plug the device into
your computer and you should see it
automatically detected if you've run
into any issues make sure you have
enabled USB debugging on the device
finally if you run into any other issues
which says could not connect to the
development server You may wish to run a
command which says ADB reverse TCP colon
8081 TCP colon 8081
doing this will set the port of your
Android device to the port of your
computer
so now we have everything set up let's
go ahead and explore the application in
its current state
I'm going to revert back to my project
set up with Expo
depending on how you set the application
up you should be presented with a basic
folder structure inside of your text
editor if the project was created using
the react native CLI you'll see a
directory with iOS and another directory
with Android
inside of these directories are native
entry points to the application we also
have our node modules and Babel setup
additionally if you set the application
up with the react native CLI you'll also
see prettier and we should also have a
file called app.js
so to make our lives easier we're going
to add a linter for working with our
project
for those of you who use the react
native CLI you should have a link to
pre-installed
but if you set the application up using
Expo you will not have this
depending on whether you're using yarn
or npm you'll need to run the following
which will install eslint as a
development dependency npm install
eslint dash dash save Dash Dev
now we can initialize eslint and we do
this by typing npx eslint dash dash init
after this is done we should have an
eslint RC file created with some setup
and we can modify this
we're also going to install the react
native Community eslint config
so we say npm install
at react native Community slash eslint
Dash config
dash dash save Dash Dev
I'm going to add a couple of extra rules
but you're welcome to customize this to
your own preference
so now we'll also need to install
prettier for helping us with our code
formatting
to do this we type npm install dash dash
save Dash Dev
dash dash save exact prettier
and now we also need to create a file
for our config so we'll type
touch.pritia.js
and we'll add the following
you can find out more about setting
config for any of these files here and
here
it's also worth adding eslint to your
text editor depending on what text
editor you have
if you're using atom you can navigate to
preferences
install
int
or if you're using vs code then you can
go to preferences
extensions eslint
if you've run into any issues you may
need to try restarting your text editor
lastly we can add a script for running
eslint inside of our package.json
so we'll call it lint
and we'll set the value to eslint Dot
to run this now all you need to do is
type npm run lint or yarn lint so when
you're working on an application it's
really useful to know how to debug the
code
in order to fix any errors that you may
create or run into
in react native we have the ability to
access what is called a debug menu
with the various ways to run the
application we have slightly different
ways to access the debug menu
if you're running the application on a
physical device you can shape the device
to access the debug menu if you're
running the application on an iOS
simulator then you can type command d
and on an Android emulator command m
if you're on a Mac or control M if
you're on a Windows
so now we should all be able to see the
debug menu and we can see the options
which are available to us
the first one is reload
whilst these days react native has hot
reloading available it's still useful to
know this option is here
you're also able to type command R so
you can do this without launching the
debug menu the next option is debug
selecting this will open the react
native debugger and once this is open
you can access the JavaScript console
just like when you're working with a
website
so you can do this in Chrome by
selecting view developer JavaScript
console
or you can type command option in j
this means we can use console logs
inside of our application and inspect
them
so let's navigate our application.js
file
I'm going to add a console log
now let's go back to Chrome
everyone can see our console log is
printed out to us
so when you're working with mobile apps
each platform has a set of native
components
whilst the names of these differ
depending on the platform the outcome is
the same they help you lay out the UI of
the application
so for example on iOS if you're working
with images you could use a UI image
View
whereas on Android you would use an
image View
on iOS this may be contained within a UI
view whereas on Android this may be
contained within a View group with react
native we use JavaScript in our
components and when the app runs react
native will then create the correct UI
for the different IOS and Android
platforms so in order for us to create
our UI react native has some core
components which we can use
if you're familiar with react you can
think of this a bit like how you use
divs and spans or P tags for your layout
here are some of the core components
that react native provides so we may
wrap our layout inside of a view and
then inside of this we may want to
display some text using the text core
component or a button using the button
component
so in our app.js file let's go ahead and
use the core text component to add some
text which we will wrap inside a view
you can think of a view a bit like div
so unless we apply styling to it the
view won't be visible
so we'll create a view and give it a
height and a width of 100.
and a background color of orange
inside of the view we'll use the text
core component and print out some text
that says hello world
now let's run this on our device
we can see The View with the orange
background which also contains our text
so you may be wondering what the syntax
is with all these tags it looks a bit
like JavaScript and HTML and it's called
jsx
jsx is an extension of JavaScript
and it stands for JavaScript and XML
so we use jsx when we're creating
elements and because it is Javascript
we're also able to use JavaScript with
it
so we could change our text to use a
variable instead
let's give this a go
so before the return statement we'll
create a variable called message
and when assigned to this our string
which says hello
now because we're going to be evaluating
a JavaScript expression when the element
is rendered we need to use a set of
curly braces
[Music]
inside of these curly braces we place
our variable so we use the message
variable here
now let's return to our simulator
nothing has changed visually but we just
used a variable to render the text
so before we start building our
application there's a few other things
we need to be aware of when we're
working with components
you need to import react and then you
need to import any of the core
components that you wish to use
your component is a constant function so
it starts with const and any jsx must be
returned
lastly you need to export the function
components and we do this using export
default
so we've come across the term component
a few times in this section
we have the core components which we
import such as View and text
but we also referred to everything in
the file as a component
we use the term element to describe what
we see on the screen
but this is contained within what we
call a component
one of the best things about react and
react native is how it makes you the
developer break down what you're
building
[Music]
the UI is separated into different
pieces
if we take a look at the open weather
map website we can see we have a
navigation bar with various links
foreign
we have a search text input we have a
map and some diagrams
and also some City details all of these
pieces can be broken down into separate
components before they are rendered on
the screen
this makes working with code a lot of
fun
but it also makes it very extensible and
clear so now we have a basic
understanding of how react native Works
let's go ahead and create our first
component
so now we have a basic understanding of
how react native Works let's go ahead
and create our first component
so in the app.js file let's delete
everything
the first thing you need to do when you
create a component is to import react
so let's go ahead and do that now
we say import
react
from
next we'll import the core components
that we are going to use
in our case we'll just use View
and text
so we say import
and then we use a set of curly braces
inside the curly braces we say View
and text
outside of the curly braces we say from
react native
there are a few different ways to create
components but we're going to use the
constant function approach described in
the last section
and we can look at these other
approaches a bit more later
we're going to call this component app
so we say const
app
followed by an equal sign
a set of parentheses
an arrow
and a set of curly braces
lastly we need to export the component
so we say export
default
app
our component does not render anything
but this is the basic setup for the
components to achieved
now we can add the jsx to return some UI
we start by using the return keyword
followed by a set of parentheses
we'll start by adding The View
and then we'll also add the text
for our text we say current
weather
so let's take a look at the simulator
it's very hard to see the text
the layout of the text will vary
slightly depending on which simulator or
emulator you're using
this is a bit like a layout on a website
varying depending on the size of the
computer screen or the different browser
for this reason just adding padding or
margins to fix the layout is not a great
approach because you might fix the
layout on one screen but it won't be
guaranteed to look better on a different
screen size or device
and you also want to be mindful that
people might be using your application
on an iPad or tablet too
so with this in mind react native
provides another core component which
can help solve this problem
it's called a safe area View
let's update our code to use this
so we start by adding it to the import
and then we'll wrap the whole element
inside of a safe area View
now if we check the simulator again we
can see the content has been rendered
just below the status bar of the device
so now we made our first component let's
move on to discussing styling
in react native we don't have access to
standard CSS
instead we use a JavaScript object
the naming of the properties is usually
the same as with standard CSS
except that we use camel casing instead
so font size becomes font size for
example
there are a few different ways to apply
the Styles but we're going to start by
using inline styles
when we use inline Styles the styles are
applied as we create the component
so we're going to start by applying a
background color of pink to our view
we'll talk about props shortly but for
now just think of them like properties
like when you add key value pairs to an
object
so we set a style prop on our view
we say Style
equals
and then a set of curly braces
inside the curly braces because we are
using inline Styles we add a second set
of curly braces
and then we say background color
a colon
and then a string with the value pink
let's save this and view it in the
simulator
we can see our screen with our pink
background color applied
so whilst this works as our code becomes
more complicated applying inline Styles
in this way can get quite messy
so as it's always good to focus on
writing quality code we're going to use
another approach and this is called
stylesheet.create
so we can Define our Styles all in one
place
to do this we need to import style sheet
from the react native API
the list of the apis we can use with
react native can be found here
so we go ahead and we create a style
object
usually it's best to do this before you
export the component
so we say const styles
equals
style sheet
Dot create
we follow this by a set of parentheses
and then a set of curly braces
because we're passing it an object
we can then go ahead and add our styles
so we're going to call this attribute
the container
and now we can add background color
now we need to add this to our component
we can remove the second set of curly
braces
and then say styles
Dot
container let's save this and view the
simulator
nothing has changed visually but we have
moved away from inline Styles and
started using stylesheet.create instead
when you're applying styles to your
component it can be useful to refer to
the documentation as these props vary
slightly depending on what core
component you're applying the styles to
you can find out more about these here
so we've just applied the background
color
but we only have the background color
around the text not the whole screen
so let's add a few other things here
we'll add a style to the safe area view
called wrapper
and apply Flex one
we'll also add Flex 1 to the container
Flex is part of the layout props
when we're building react native
applications positioning and layout is
done using flexbox and the reason for
this is that it lets us build our
layouts for the various different screen
sizes that we will encounter
so unlike with the web you don't have to
say display Flex for those of you who
aren't familiar
Flex will Define how much of the screen
The View should fill and you provide a
value from zero upwards
so we're saying Flex of one
and this is the equivalent of saying the
view should fill the entire screen
because we're only using one View group
when you want to start to split the view
into different areas you may need to
start to consider the different values
depending on how much space you want
each part of the screen to fill
so if you're using Flex one then all the
components up the tree must also use
flex one
which is why we also apply it to the
outer safe area View
let's also make our title display in the
center of the screen
we can do this by saying align items
Center
so this centers the text horizontally
if we wanted to display the text in the
center vertically we would just use
justify content
we want our text to just be centered
horizontally
so the goal for this screen is to show
the user the current weather
we want to display the actual
temperature what the temperature feels
like
the high and low values
and then we want to display a
description and some additional text
about the weather
lastly we also want to display an icon
and a background color
eventually we want this screen to be
dynamic so the icon background color and
message that we provide change depending
on the weather
for now though let's just hard code
everything in so that we can get our
basic layout and once we have looked at
getting the data from the API we can
update this so it works dynamically
so let's start by adding our text for
the first value that we want to add
which will be the temperature
and for now we'll just add six for the
value
we'll add another text for the fields
so we'll say fields
like
five
let's add the high and low in another
text
so we say hi
colon
eight
and low
colon
six
so let's start by adding the layout
styles for these
we'll start with the temperature and
we'll call this temp
we'll give this a color of black
and a font size
of 48.
you don't use units just the numbers for
the Styles and react native
all dimensions in react native are
unitless and represent density
independent pixels
so this is an absolute unit of
measurement for the device
for the feels like text We'll add some
Styles called feels
foreign
and this will have a font size
of 30
and a color
of black
we also don't now need our title so
let's delete that
let's also add some styles for the high
and low text
we'll apply this to both pieces of the
text and we'll call it styles
Dot
high low
we will give this a color of black
and a font size
of 20.
let's view the simulator and see what
we've done so far
we want the text for the high value and
the text for the low value to appear on
the same line
to do this we can set the flex direction
to use row
we'll start by making a container for
these pieces of text and then set the
flex Direction on the container so that
it applies to the children which is the
high and low text
so we start by wrapping both pieces of
text in a view
and we'll call the styles for this Hi-Lo
wrapper
we'll then say Flex Direction
right
now if we check on the device again we
can see the high and low text both
appear on the same line
on the bottom of the screen we want to
add some more details about the current
weather conditions so we'll create
another view
and inside this we'll place two pieces
of text
inside the first text we'll say it's
sunny
and inside the second we'll say it's
perfect t-shirt weather
we want this text to show at the bottom
of the screen so let's apply some styles
we'll call the attribute body wrapper
and set justify content to flex end
this is so that it displays on the
bottom of the screen
let's also add align items
with flex start
so that the text displays on the far
left of the screen
we're also going to change our container
so that it only wraps the items we want
to display on the top portion of the
screen
so we'll move the closing brace for this
view to be just before the view of the
body wrapper attributes
now let's also apply some styles to the
text with the weather description
we'll call the first one description
and we'll call the second one
message
inside description let's add a font size
of 48.
and let's make the message a bit smaller
so this one will have a font size
of 30.
now let's check the simulator
we have our basic layout set up
but it doesn't really look very pretty
nor is it very dynamic
we also see that our background color
does not apply to the whole screen
this is because we changed the container
to only wrap the items at the top of the
screen
we can fix this by moving the background
color into the safe area view wrapper
let's do this now
let's check the simulator again
and we can see everything now looks as
we expect
in the next section we'll look at adding
an image to the screen
so we want to display an icon that
represents the weather to the user
there are a few ways we could do this
but I'm going to use a library which is
installed by default when we use create
Expo app
if you did not create the app using Expo
you can manually install it now
it's called react native Vector icons
and it provides us with a variety of
icons that we can use within our project
the library Expo installs is built on
top of the react native Vector icons one
to explore the Expo items you can see
them here
for now we just want to use an icon that
represents sunshine so let's search for
this
when we click on the icon it provides us
with the details we need to use the icon
so to start we need to import the icon
family
next we need to add the icon to our
component
we're going to show the icon at the top
of the screen
let's also change the size to be 100 so
it's a bit bigger
let's have a quick look on the simulator
and see how this looks now so we can see
the icon has been successfully added to
our screen
the top part of the screen is starting
to look quite busy so let's Center all
of this content by adding justify
content Center to the container
let's also add some left padding to the
text at the bottom of the screen
so I'll add padding left
with the value of 25.
and a margin bottom of 40.
so in react native when we're adding
things like margins and padding we can
either provide a single value to the
padding or margin which will affect the
top right bottom and left alternatively
we can apply separate values to the
different areas like we're doing
now we have our first component so we
can look and moving on to using it with
real data
we're going to start by moving our
current weather component into another
component
there are a few different approaches you
can use in terms of structuring your app
and these often vary depending on the
complexity of the application
we're going to start by creating a
directory called SRC
inside of this we're going to create
another directory called components
inside of the components directory let's
create a file called current weather
dot Js
so let's paste everything from the app
file into the current weather component
let's also rename the component from app
to current weather
we also need to make sure it's exported
now inside the app file let's delete
everything
let's redefine our component again
so we say const
app
equals
and then we use an arrow function
with parentheses
at the bottom of the file we say export
default
app
inside the body let's add return
with some parentheses
we'll also import react
and let's also import View
from react native
lastly we'll also import stylesheet
let's set up the styles
so we say const
styles
equals
style sheet
Dot
create
and we'll set an attribute called
container
we'll give this a flex of one
let's now add the view to our component
and we can apply the styles
we also want to use our current weather
component so we'll import this to start
with
we say import
and say current weather
and then we need to provide the path
that we want to get the file from
now all we have left to do is to render
this inside of the component
let's save this and check everything
worked in the simulator
everything looks good
so before we go any further let's take a
step back and review what we have just
learned
so far we have learned how to set up an
app with Expo
we have looked at how to create and
import a component
and we've also looked at basic styling
for our components
a component is a function that returns
some amount of jsx
the jsx is the syntax we use to make our
lives easier for readability purposes
but under the hood jsx gets turned into
JavaScript by using babble
and you can see more about the
conversion here
inside of our components we show
or render something to show the user
we can then export the component and use
it elsewhere in our application
when it comes to importing a component
into another component we use the
keyword import and relative path
so we don't have to append the dot Js
when we work with react native we are
working with a framework that promotes
lots of component reuse because it's a
component-based framework
so in our application we'll usually have
a root component which in our case is
the app.js file and this acts as the
entry point for the application
but then we'll usually have multiple
other components which are usually
stored inside of a directory called
components
inside these components we may then
import additional components
so for example we may create a custom
button and reuse it throughout our
application as opposed to redefining it
in multiple places
as a side note you're able to have more
than one component in a file but just
having the one makes the code much
easier to work with and this is very
important especially when there's more
than one developer working on a project
so this component-based architecture not
only helps with debugging and easier
testing
but there's also a convention encoding
called dry which stands for don't repeat
yourself
it's good to have this at the back of
your mind when you're working with a
component-based framework
so our app is going to have two
additional screens
one which will show the upcoming weather
and one which will show some details
about the local city to the user
as we're still getting familiar with
react native we're going to move on to
implementing the initial layout for
these screens first
after we've done this we'll have a look
at how to make them Dynamic by fetching
data from the open Weather API
and then we'll look at how we can wire
up all these screens together with
navigation
so we're going to start by creating the
component to show the upcoming weather
we'll call this component upcoming
weather
so we can create a file inside of our
components directory
let's also create the boilerplate for
our component
so we say const
upcoming weather
equals and then we use a set of
parentheses an arrow function
and a set of curly braces
we'll also make sure to export the
component so we say export default
upcoming weather
we need to import react from react
foreign
safe area View
from react native
inside of the component we'll say return
and we'll add a set of parentheses
inside of the parentheses We'll add the
tags for the safe area View
let's also set up our styles
so we add style sheet to the react
native import
then before our component is exported we
say const styles
equals
stylesheet
dot create
we add some parentheses
and curly braces
we'll also create a container and we'll
add this to the safe area View
we'll give this Flex of one
let's also add some text
so we need to import this
and now we can create the text
we'll give this the message upcoming
weather
in order to check we've set up the
component correctly we can view it in
the simulator
before we do this though we'll need to
add the component to our app.js file
so at the top of the file just like we
did with current weather
let's import the file now
then in the render let's remove current
weather
and add the upcoming weather
let's check the simulator
we can see our component has been set up
correctly
and we get to see the upcoming weather
text we added
so what are our goals for this component
well we want to be able to show the user
a list and in the list we want to show
the user the date and time
an icon
and what the weather will be at that
time
before we do this we need to have a look
at how lists work in react native as
showing lists to a user is a core part
of working with mobile apps and it's
something you're likely to come across
very often
so rendering lists inside of mobile apps
is a common task you may find yourself
presented with
take a look at your favorite social
media app
or have a look at a news app
because of the often limited screen size
we have on a mobile device
very often the information is displayed
to us in the form of a list
and we have to think carefully about how
we go about using it in order to make
the best of the screen space we have
available to us
so in react native when we work with
lists we have a choice of a few core
components that we can use
primarily these are called Flat list and
section list
additionally we have virtualized lists
but it's better to try and use the flat
list or section list components because
virtualized list is essentially a
diluted version of these and unless you
need a heavy amount of flexibility you
should be able to fulfill your needs
with the flat list or section list
components
so what's the difference between flat
list and section list
there are a few differences in the way
you implement the two which we'll look
at shortly
but in terms of the end result if you
simply have a list that you want to
display to the user then you can use
flat list
we can take a look at the example on the
react native website
so we see three items in the list here
if I try to scroll
well not a lot happens
however if I add a few more items to the
list we can see what happens when the
list is bigger
I'll add three more items
and just amend the title and ID
properties slightly
so now we see our longer list and we can
scroll through the list here like so
let's also have a quick look at section
list
so here we can see the list
but we can also see how it's broken up
into sections and each section has its
own items
so we have main dishes
sides
drinks and so on
so the outcome here is that if you have
a collection of data that you need to
display to the user which needs to be
broken into sections then you should use
section list
otherwise flat list will suffice
so let's move on to looking at how these
lists are implemented
on the right hand side here I can see
all the properties that are available to
us to use
however there are two of these props
with a red dot next to them
if we scroll down the documentation a
bit we can see that these are marked as
required
so all the other props are optional but
render item and sections are compulsory
equally if we go ahead and look back at
flat list we can see there are again a
lot of props available to us but this
time we have two marked with a red dot
render item and data
so the takeaway here is that both lists
are heavily customizable but both have
two things that you need to provide in
order to implement them
we are going to be using flat list in
our app so let's start with looking more
deeply at this one
the first one of the required props is
data and for this we need to pass an
array
inside of the array we have the data
that we want to be displayed on the
screen
so if your list was showing a list of
cars then you may have an array
containing names of cars
if your list was displaying a list of
students test results then perhaps you
would have an array containing the
students names and their test scores
with flat list you're able to Simply
pass in an array let me update the code
here to show this
I'm going to remove all the objects
and then I'll simply pass in the titles
to the array
so I'll also remove the title keys
in the item function I'll also remove
the reference to title
and simply refer to the item itself
so now when the list renders I can see
the three items from the data array
it's worth pointing out here that this
is one of the differences between flat
list and section list
in that with Section list you must pass
in an array of objects because of the
fact the list is broken up into sections
in reality when you're working with flat
list
because quite often you're rendering
Dynamic data such as that from an API
you're probably more likely to end up
also passing in an array containing
objects too
so now we understand the required data
property let's have a look at the second
required property which was called
render item
the render item prop gets past a
function and this will get called on
every array element
its job is to decide how that element
then gets displayed to the user
so you can think of it a bit like the
List's own render function
if the function for rendering the item
is very simple we can place it directly
in the definition for the flat list
quite often though we end up passing it
a reference to a function as we may want
to render out quite a few things for our
list element we pass a single argument
to the function which is an object
and this is the item you are rendering
so if I refresh the screen and go back
to the original example here we can see
it renders the title from each item in
the data array
so if I added another property to the
items in the data array let's say amount
and then I pass that into the render
item
and render an additional piece of text
to render the amount
we then get to see that each item in the
list renders this value too
if you're working with Section list then
render item Works in a similar way
so before we move on and look at
implementing a list in our app let's
recap everything we've just looked at
with lists
we've learned that in react native we
have two main core components that we
can use when we're working with lists
flat list and section list
we know that flat list is more of a
standard list
but we can use section list if our data
needs to be displayed in sections
we then looked at what we need to do to
get our list up and running
we've seen that we must pass in some
data which must be an array
and if we're using section list then
this must also be an array containing
objects
we've also seen that we must
additionally use a prop called render
item and we use this to display the list
element to the user
so let's now move back to our code and
figure out how we're going to use a list
so back in our upcoming weather
component let's start by importing the
flat list core component
so inside the react native Imports we
just say flat list
now under our upcoming weather text
let's use this
so we start by typing flat list
we know we need the required data and
render item props so let's add these two
obviously at the moment we have not yet
set up our app to fetch any data so for
now let's write this out by hand
we'll start by declaring the variable
for data outside of our component and we
say const
data
and will assigned this the required
array
inside the array I'm going to just Place
three objects as for now this will be
enough before we wire up our app to use
the real data later
if we have a look at the open Weather
API documentation we can see some
examples of the data sent back to us
there is obviously a lot we can work
with here but for our list we're just
going to be sharing the weather at three
hour intervals and we only need a few
bits of data from the response
we'll want to use DT text for the
current time
the Min and Max temperature
and a description of the weather
so I'm just going to paste in some
example code here and you can pause the
video now if you're following along
so now we have our data we can pass this
into the flat list
so we should have our data prop defined
we use an equal sign and a curly brace
and then pass in the data
the next required prop we need to add is
render item
we're going to create a function to pass
into this which will render what we want
to show to the user
in our case we're going to create a
separate component for the item so we
want render item to render the component
that we'll be creating
let's start by creating the component
for the item
I mentioned earlier that it's best to
keep components in their own files but
whilst we're setting up our list I'm
going to create it in this file and then
when we do some refactoring we can move
it later
so we're going to call this component
item
so we Define it just like we have with
all our other components
we say const
then the component name which is item an
equal sign an arrow and some curly
braces we then say return with some
parentheses
we're going to be rendering the DT text
min
and Max weather
and then the weather condition
let's add these props now
I'm going to Define props in the
parameter
and then using destructuring I'll pull
these out
so I say const
a set of curly braces
an equal sign
and props
this is a convenient and clean way to
access props inside of your components
inside the curly braces I'll add DT text
men
Max
and condition
now inside the return let's start by
adding a wrapper or container
so I'll add a view here
inside the view I'll add three pieces of
text
in the first piece of text We'll add the
DT text prop
so I need to use curly braces because
we're using a prop
in the second I'll add min
and in the third I'll add Max
I'm also going to add an icon which will
go above all the pieces of text
I'm going to do this using Expo icons
again so we need to import this
under our react native Imports let's say
import
then we have our curly braces
and inside this we say feather
then we say from
at explo
slash Vector icons
we're going to be dynamically using
different icons based on the weather
condition
but for now let's just add one to the
name Sun as we're going to need to
create a file which handles some of the
configuration for us later in order to
correctly map the feather icon names
with the open weather map weather
descriptions
so I add feather at the top of the view
I then set a name prop which is equal to
Sun
we set the size to be 50.
because we're using a list and we don't
want the icon to be too huge
and then we set the color to white
so now we have our list item component
let's create the render item function
inside of the upcoming weather component
so before the return keyword we say
const
render item
and then we set this up like an arrow
function
so we use an equal sign
parentheses
an arrow
and because we want to render something
we'll use another set of parentheses
for the parameter we want to pass in the
item so we use a set of curly braces and
pass in the item
we need to pass the required props to
the item component
so we say condition
and set this equal to be item
Dot
weather
we use square brackets to get the
element at the position of zero
then Dot
Main
we set the DT text
and this is equal to item
Dot
DT text
we then set them in which is equal to
item
Dot
Main
temp min
and then Max which is equal to item
Dot
Main
temp Max
now in our flat list all we need to do
is pass in this function
so we say render item and pass in render
item
let's save this and run the app in the
simulator to see where everything is at
so in the simulator we see the upcoming
weather text but then we see the three
items from the data that we passed into
the flat list rendered on the screen
obviously it doesn't look very pleasing
but we can address that in a moment
before we do that though there's one
other thing we need to add to our flat
list
if we take a look back at the docs on
the website we can see the example also
include something called a key extractor
what is this
well let's read through the description
it says it is used to extract a unique
key for a given item at a specified
index
key is used for caching and as the react
key to track the item reordering
the default extractor checks item dot
key then item.id
and then falls back to using the index
like reactors
so to summarize when you're working with
lists you need to provide a unique key
to each element in the data
the reason behind this is largely
Performance Based and it means that
under the hood react native is able to
keep track of each item in the list
imagine you're working with a really
long list
say one with over 100 pieces of data
when something in the list changes
for example if an element was deleted
then because of the way react native
works when the re-rendering happens
everything would get rebuilt from
scratch
by providing the key it means the
different item changes this is not
necessary and instead the list can be
recalculated
and as such that this can be updated
rather than rebuilt
the requirements for the key are that it
must be a string and each element must
have its own unique ID
we can either add a key to each element
in our data
or we can use key extractor to add the
key for us
in our data we could go ahead and add
keys to each item
but because each item has its own DT
text key and value which because it's
based on a timestamp is unique for each
item we're going to use that for the key
so let's start by adding the key
extractor to the flat list
so all we have to do inside curly braces
now is say item
Arrow
and item.dt text
as a side note if you ever see this
warning then it's essentially telling
you that this is what you need to do to
fix it
before we move on to making our list
look a bit better let's just have a
quick look at some of the other props
which are available to us to use on the
list if we wanted
so we have item separator component
which is something that gets rendered
between each item in the list this would
be good for visual purposes if you
wanted to add something that distinctly
separates each item in the list
let's try it out
so I type item
separator
component
an equal sign
and then I'm going to add an inline
function
I'll add a view
and now I'll add some Styles here
so I say background color
red
and height
two
so now in the list I can see this is
rendered between each item
let's refresh the screen
list empty component is another useful
prop to know about
it means that if the list is empty it
will automatically display some other
content to the user which is a great
consideration if you are depending on
data fetching
so I start by creating a component
called empty
I'll give this a view
and I'll add some text
and for the text I'll just say empty
now in the list I Define the list empty
component prop
and I pass in my empty component
so now if I update the data array so
it's empty
we get to see this in action
and I see the empty component instead
displayed on the screen
there's also a list header and list
footer which means we could display
either a header or footer in our list
there's obviously a lot you can do with
your lists and it's good to spend some
time getting familiar with the
documentation here and playing about
with everything
the main things you must remember though
are that you need to provide the render
item and data to the flat list and you
need to provide a key of some sort to
the data
you don't need to worry too deeply about
performance especially if you aren't
working with a very large list because
flat list only gets re-rendered if the
data changes and only renders the items
currently displaying on the screen not
everything at once
but as you start to build bigger and
bigger lists it's important to have
performance at the back of your mind
when you're building out the list
so let's go back to our code and see
what we can do to make everything a bit
more visually pleasing
the first thing you may have noticed
when we check the simulator was that you
could not see the icon
the reason for this is that the icon
color is white and we have not added any
background color to our screen
so this is currently defaulting as white
2.
so let's start by updating the style
attributes in our container
I'm going to start by importing status
bar to our react native Imports
and inside the style sheet I'll add
margin top
and I'll set this equal to status bar
Dot
current height
or
zero
this is basically a constant from the
status bar component which means we're
taking into account both platforms and
saying to initialize with the current
height of the status bar for Android or
use xero
next I'm going to set a background color
to red
now I'm going to set the view of the
item
to be Style
equals
styles
Dot
item
I'll add this to the style sheet
I'm going to set padding
to be 20.
margin vertical
to be eight margin horizontal
to be 16.
I'm going to set a flex Direction
of rho
and justify content
to be spaced around
this is so the items in the row are
evenly distributed
I'll set align items
to be Center
border width
to be five
and also a background color
to be pink
next I'm going to set Style
equals
styles
Dot
temp
on both the min
and Max temperatures I'll add this to
the style sheet
I'll give this a color
of white
and a font size of 20.
lastly our set Style
equals
styles
Dot
date
onto the DT text
and in the style sheet we'll add this
we'll set color
to be white
and font size
to be 15.
let's save this and view it in the
simulator
we can now see everything and the list
items are much more distinct we
obviously have some way to go with this
still but it's a good start
the next two things that we're going to
do are add an image to this component
which will let us discuss how to use
images in react native and then distract
out the item component into its own
component which will let us do a bit of
refactoring and also talk a bit more
deeply about props in react native but
let's start by looking at how we go
about using images in react native
so in react native we have a few
different options available for when it
comes to working with images for example
local or network images
on the example on the react native
website we can see both of these
approaches in action
so we can see the image core component
imported and then used
we can see that a source prop is set in
the first image so this differs slightly
from the web where you may use SRC and
now we have the full word source
a require statement is then placed
followed by the path to the image
the other way to load the image is by
using a network image and this means we
load the image from a URL instead
this is more standard practice when
you're working with API requests
so we can see here we use the source
prop again but this time we pass in an
object with a URI key and the URL is set
as the value
there are a few other caveats worth
pointing out when you're working with
images
if you're using a network image you need
to explicitly State a height for the
image
you should also be aware of the
supported types of images in react
native
additionally when you're sizing the
images in general you can give the image
a fixed height and width or you can use
aspect ratio with height and or the
width to size the image
lastly it's worth being mindful of image
storage sizes when you're using static
images so not the network images
as these will get bundled when you ship
your application and if you have a lot
of images that you can start to eat up
memory
if you've seen file names with 2X and 3X
for images it's because it's standard
practice to provide the same image in
three sizes in order to account for the
different screen resolutions
so we're going to get an image to use
for our app from website which provides
royalty-free stock images it's called
pixabay
if you navigate to the pixabay website
and then search for clouds
whilst you're welcome to use any of
these images I'm going to use this one
here
so I'll select the image
and then I'll select to download the
image
back in our app I store the image in the
assets directory which is where we store
static content
so we could actually add another folder
here for the images but I'm just going
to add it straight into the directory
so now we are ready to use the image at
our upcoming weather component
we need to start by importing the core
image component inside of our react
native Imports
now inside the render under the text I'm
going to add the image
so I add image
and the self-closing tags
I then type source
an equal sign
and some curly braces
inside the curly braces I say require
and a set of parentheses
and then I type the path to the image
I'm also going to set some Styles so I
say Style
equals
styles
Dot
image
I then set this inside of the style
sheet so I say image here too
I'll give this a height of 100 and a
width
of also 100. let's save this and view it
in the simulator
so we can see our image has rendered
successfully
the problem with this approach for us is
that we're going to want to display the
image as the background to the screen
and we can't give children to the image
component
in cases like this there is another core
component that we can use instead and
this is called image background
image background works much like image
as the documentation here says you can
add whatever children to it that you
would like to layer on top of it
that's the perfect behavior that we're
looking for
so let's go back to our code and we'll
add in image background
so back in our upcoming weather
component let's change the import from
image to the image background
now inside the safe area view just
before the text let's move our image
here
and we'll change it to be image
background
because this is now going to accept
children we want to change it not to use
self-closing tags
so we'll add a closing tag before the
closing tag of the safe area View
we're also going to change the styles to
use flex of one
lastly let's also change the background
color in the safe area view to be
something that blends in better with our
image
so we'll use royal blue here
as a side note you can see all the
colors available to use with react
native here
so we can see now we have our image
background applied and our safe area
view Blends in with the image much
better
so earlier in the course I mentioned we
would take some time to understand what
props are in react native
if you've worked with react before then
they're the same in react native
for those of you who are new to react
and react native it's important to
understand props as they are a key
feature of react native
so what are props
the term prop is just short for property
so when you create an object in
JavaScript you add properties to the
object and you give the properties a
value
so for example if you created a dog
object as dogs have legs then legs could
be added to the dog object as a property
and then given a value which most of the
time would probably be for
in react native we can think of props in
a similar fashion
they adjust properties which are given a
value of some sort
but they're used as way to pass our data
down from the parent to a child
so to visualize this a bit more clearly
imagine we had a house component
and this would be the parent
we want the house component to render a
room component
this will be our child
and we want this to render four times
because our house is going to have four
rooms
when the room component gets rendered we
want to be able to pass down the name of
the person whose room it is
so to implement this we would have the
house component and every time you
render the room
we would set a room owner as a prop
inside of the room component we would be
able to access the Ramona prop and use
this in some way
so for example we could set a piece of
text which would display the value of
the Ramona
so instead of creating four separate
room components we just have the one and
each time it's customized to our
requirements
so now hopefully we better understand
that we can use props to customize our
components
when we added the image background core
component to our upcoming weather
component we used a prop called Source
in order to set the image
which would be displayed to the user
core components inside react native
usually come with props which can be
used
if I take a look at the text core
component I can see the list of props
available to us
so for example I could set the Ellipsis
mode or disabled
the same was true when we worked with
flat list and we had to set the data and
render item props
just like with the core components in
react native we can use props in our own
components and by doing so we can
customize a component
but it also means that we're able to
make the component more reusable and
component reusability is a key concept
when you're working with react or react
native
so back in our app let's look at a
little demo of this in action
we won't use this in our final code but
I'm going to create a file called our
child
dot Js
we'll set this up like a basic component
so I start by importing react
from react
I'll then import View
and text
from react native
once the component is set up and
exported I'll say return and then I'm
going to use a set of parentheses I'll
then render a view and also some text
I'm going to use inline Styles here as
this is just a demo so I'll give this a
height
of 200.
and a width
of also 200.
and I'll also set a background color
of red
inside the text I'm going to want to set
some text to display
so this is where we're going to display
a prop the prop will be sent down from
the parent
which in our case for this example will
be the app.js file
the name of the prop
will be message
so to display the value of the prop we
need to use curly braces
so I typed the curly braces
and then the prop name which is message
we also need to set the prop as an
argument into the component itself and
we do this inside of curly braces here
alternatively we can just say props here
and then destructure the value
so now let's go back to our app.js file
and here we can render the archile
component
for this example I'm going to remove the
upcoming weather component temporarily
so we need to start by importing the r
child component
and then we're going to want to use this
three times
each time we want to use a different
value for the message prop
so we start by adding the prop
and then we use an equal sign
and some curly braces
inside the curly braces we can set the
value
the first one will say hello
the second one will say greetings
and the third one will say goodbye
let's save this and view it in the
simulator
when the app runs we can see our child
component is rendered three times
and each time through the use of props
the message is displayed with its
different values
before we review what we've just learned
let's revert the app.js file back to
what we need for our app
so we'll delete the references to the r
child component
we will also put back the upcoming
weather component
lastly let's go ahead and delete the r
child component
just before I do this I want to point
out one other thing with regards to file
and folder structure
we'll come back to this later but it's
better practice once you start using
components to have a directory structure
where you have a folder for your screens
in the app
and then a component folder where you
store your components
so the screens are like the screen as
the user will visually see so for
example upcoming weather would be a
screen
but then we have a component folder
where you store your components which
are reusable components and the code for
things like UI such as buttons and
perhaps alerts or Footers
so now let's delete the r child
component
before we move on let's just recap what
we've just looked at
we have just looked at what props are
and how they let you pass in data from a
parent to a child in order to promote
component reuse in react native
we've also looked at props with core
react native components and also with
custom components
there are a few more points to consider
when you're working with props and these
are really really important to have at
the back of your mind firstly props are
immutable
this means that they can't be changed
once the component is created
we pass the props from the parent to the
child as we've just discussed
we use unidirectional data flow when
we're working with react and react
native
essentially this means that data is only
able to move in one direction from the
parent to the child
the outcome of this is that our lives
are much easier
imagine if you're driving on a road
and cars could drive in both directions
you'd have a collision pretty quickly
this would be the same scenario with our
data so unidirectional data flow keeps
things straightforward
so now we are all much more familiar
with how props work and we should
hopefully now be becoming more familiar
with react native itself
let's take a bit of a pause and do some
refactoring to the current state of our
application
in the last section I mentioned that one
approach to structuring code is to split
the code into components and screens
and then I discussed the benefits around
doing this as you start to use more
components within your screens
in this section we're going to do this
then we're going to move the item
component for the upcoming weather flat
list into its own file inside the
components directory
we'll also do some other General
refactoring so our code is a bit easier
to work with moving forwards
so to start
in our SRC directory
let's create another directory called
screens
now let's move the current weather
and the upcoming weather components into
this directory
these components are core screens for
our application so it makes sense this
is where they are stored
now we need to go through these files
and check there are no Imports we need
to update
and then we also need to check the same
thing in the other place these files are
used which is in the app.js file
it's important to follow this process
every time you extract some code
otherwise when you run the app you'll
run into errors so let's try running the
app in the simulator now to check that
nothing has broken
great
everything looks okay
the next thing we're going to want to do
is to create a file for the item
component which is rendered by our flat
list inside the upcoming weather screen
so inside of the components directory
I'm going to create a file
and for the sake of being a bit more
descriptive I'm going to call this list
item
next I'll copy and paste the code from
the upcoming weather component
into the list item component
I'll also need to update the Imports so
I say import
react
from
and then I'll also import
View
and text
from react native
additionally I need to import feather
inside curly braces
from at Expo
slash
Vector icons
then we also need to make sure the
component is exported so it can be used
within the upcoming weather screen
so I say export
default
list item
the next thing we need to do is import
stylesheet into our react native Imports
and then we need to set up the styles
so before the component is exported I
say const
styles
equals
stylesheet
Dot
create
then I need to use a set of parentheses
and a set of curly braces
so we're going to need to bring the
Styles over from the upcoming weather
component but obviously we only need to
use the relevant Styles here
so I'll need the item date and temp
styles
I'll grab these now
and then I can also delete these in the
upcoming weather component
additionally I can now delete item in
the upcoming weather component
and then I need to change the render
item to return the list item component
as opposed to item
we're already setting the props for the
component here but let's check this is
all properly set up in our list item
component too
everything looks good
I see prop set as the parameter
and we already have the destructuring
for the props in place
so now the last thing I need to do is
import list item into the upcoming
weather component
so I say import
list item
from
and then I add the path which is
components
slash list item
I'll also remove the view from the react
native Imports here as this is no longer
needed
for the sake of making our code as clean
as possible we can also destructure our
styles
so before the return
I say const
then I use a set of curly braces
and then I say equals
styles
inside the curly braces I'll Place
container
and image
inside the render I can then remove the
Styles and the dot for these attributes
I'll do the same in the list item
component
so before the return I say const
I use a set of curly braces
and say equals
styles
inside the curly braces I place item
date
and temp
inside the return I can then remove the
Styles and the dot for these attributes
let's save this and check everything has
worked in the simulator
so visually nothing has changed but
we're now using the list item component
from inside of its own file when we use
render item inside the flat list
before we move on to looking at how to
wire up our screens with navigation
there is one other screen we're going to
implement
this screen will show some details about
the current weather location
so let's set up the boilerplate for this
screen now and then we'll look at what
will be shown on the screen
this component will be called City
so inside of our screens directory we
can create a new file and call it City
dot Js
inside the file we do our standard setup
so we import
react
from
and then we'll import safe area View
text
and style sheet
from react native
then we'll set up our component
so I say const
City
equals
then I use a set of parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
next I'll export the component
so at the bottom of the file I say
export
default
City
inside of the curly braces
I say return
and then use some parentheses
for now I'll just add the safe area View
and inside this some text
fill the text
for now we'll just say City
let's add some basic Styles here to get
this set up
so before the component is exported I'll
say const
styles
equals
style sheet
Dot
create
I'll then add a set of parentheses
and some curly braces
next I'm going to add an attribute
called container
and I'll give this Flex of one
lastly I'll add this to the safe area
view so I say Style
equals
and some curly braces
and then I just add styles
Dot
container
now let's add this screen to our app.js
file to check everything is rendering
correctly
so back in our app.js file I start by
adding the import
and then for now I'll remove upcoming
weather
and change this to show the city screen
instead
let's save this and check the simulator
on the simulator now we can see that our
new screen is rendering correctly
so what do we want this screen to do
well the city screen will be quite a
simple screen
it'll have an image background which
will be City related
and then it will show the name and the
country of the city
it will show the population of the city
and also the time that the sun rises and
the sun sets
let's start by finding the image which
we'll use for the screen's background
image
and then search for City
just like with the upcoming weather
screen you can use any image you want
here but I'm going to use this one here
so I'll select the image
and then select to download the image
once the image is downloaded I'll move
it into my assets directory for
Simplicity I'll also rename this to city
background
now let's go back to our city component
we're going to start by adding image
background to our react native Imports
then inside the save area view let's
remove the text
we'll then need to add image background
we know for the image background we need
to add the source prop
so let's do that now
we say source
equals
and then some curly braces
inside of the curly braces we say
require and then add the path to our
image
we also know that we're probably going
to want to add some styles for this so
let's do that now too
we say style equals
and then we'll call this image layout
so we say Styles dot image layout inside
of our style sheet let's also add image
layout here
and we'll give this Flex
of one
whilst we're here let's also update the
margin top of the status bar for Android
just like we did in the upcoming weather
component so we say margin top and then
we give this the value of status bar dot
current height or
zero and then we need to add status bar
to our react native Imports
when we discuss this component I said
we'll need the city name and Country
and then we'll also add the population
and then the sunrise and sunset times
so let's start by adding two pieces of
text for the city name and Country
will hard coding these values for now
so for the name I'll say London
and for the country
I'll say UK
let's also add some styles for these
for the city name we'll call the
attribute city name
and for the country
we'll call the attribute country name
let's add these to our style sheet
so for the city name
I'm going to say justify content of
Center
aligned self
of Center
font size
of 40
font weight
of bold
and color
of white
next with the country name
I'll say justify content
of Center
Airline self
font size
of 30
color
of white
and font weight
of bold
before we go any further let's just stop
for a moment and take a look at the
styles for the city name and country
name
apart from the font size all these
styles are the same
we like to try and keep our code as
clean and tidy as possible and when we
start to see duplication it's a sign
that it's possible that we could be
doing something a bit better
in react native we're able to pass in
multiple styles to the style prop by
using array notation
so if you're working on the web you
might use multiple class names
but in react native we pass the array of
the styles to the style prop
and these will get merged into one
object
if you have any duplication in these
Styles it will be the last definition
that is used
this approach is very useful if we have
a theme and then we want to use that
theme in multiple places
but then we also have some additional
unique styles to apply to
so in the style sheet I'm going to
create a new attribute called City text
and I'm going to move everything inside
of this
I'll then remove font size
as this is the value that will be unique
for each bit of text
inside country name and city name
I'll remove everything except the font
size
now back in the render
inside of the style prop for both of
these pieces of text we need to add an
array
inside of the array We'll add City text
but then we're also going to make sure
that the city name and the country name
also remain as this is where the font
sizes come from
so the next thing we want to add to our
screen is the population
for this we're going to show an icon of
a person and some text
because we want to be rendering both of
these elements and also that we want
them to show on a row we're going to
wrap these inside of a container
so I'm going to start by adding a view
to the react native Imports
and whilst I'm here I'm also going to
import feather again
so I say import
then I use curly braces
and inside the curly braces
I say feather
from
at Expo slash Vector icons
then I'll go back to the render
and I'll start by adding The View
inside the view I'll add feather
and also some text
so let's go and look for an icon that we
can use with this component on the Expo
icon site I'll search for a user icon
and then I'll select this one here
I can copy the details into the
component
I'm going to amend the size to be 50.
and change the color to be red
now in the text
let's add another hard-coded value
obviously this is way off for the
population size for London but I'm just
going to say 8 000 for now
so to make sure these elements render in
a row and to make the text look a bit
better let's add some styles
I'll set a style for the view called
population wrapper
and I'll set the style for the text to
be population text
let's add these to the style sheet
so I'll start with population wrapper
I'll say Flex direction of row
align items of Center
justify content of Center
and margin top
of 30.
for the population text I'll say font
size
of 25.
foreign
left
of seven
point five
I'll set color
to be red
and font weight
to be bold
the last details we need to add to this
screen are the sunrise and the sunset
again these are going to want to be
rendered in a row
and I'm going to want to use icons and
text for both of these I'll start by
adding a view
and then I'll add feather
and also some text
and then I'll repeat this again
so I'll add feather
and also some text
so let's start by going back to the Expo
icon site and look for a sunrise icon
this one looks perfect so I'll copy the
details
and I'll add it to the component
let's also do the same for sunset
so I'll navigate back to the Expo site
and our search for sunset
and then I can copy and add the details
to the component
for both icons I'm going to update the
size
to be 50.
and I'll also update the color
to be white
I'm now just going to hard code in some
values for the sunrise and the sunset
times
for Sunrise I'll say 10 colon
46 colon
am
for the sunset
I'll say 17
colon
15.
P.M
now let's add some Styles here
I'm going to add a rise set wrapper
to the view container for these elements
then I'll add Rye set text both pieces
of text
let's navigate back to our style sheet
and we'll add in these attributes
so I'll start with the Rye set wrapper
I'll give this a flex direction of row
I'll say align items
of Center
justify content
space around
and margin top
of 30.
let's also add the rise set text
and this will have a font size
of 20.
a color
of white
and a font weight
of bold
let's save this and see where things are
at in the simulator
so when our app runs we're now able to
see the city screen with the
requirements we Define for the screen
we have our image background and the
city name and location
we also have an icon for the population
and some text for the population
and then we have our sunrise and sunset
images and text
I keep going on about how we'll shortly
look at navigation to wire up our
screens and I promise we'll get there
shortly I have a few last bits of
refactoring I want to do to the current
state of our application before we move
on
so firstly if we navigate back to our
city screen and take a look at our
component
there are three places in the render
part of this component where we use a
feather icon and then a piece of text
this is a great example of when we could
extract out something to be a component
we don't have any need to be writing
this out three times
instead we can have a component that
renders this and accepts props for the
image type and the text which we need to
show
so let's go ahead and do this now
we'll start by creating a file in our
components directory called icon text
once this is created we can navigate to
the component and set up our boilerplate
so we say import
react
from
we know we need to show some text in
this component and we also want to wrap
this in a view
so next let's import View
and text
from
react native
we also know this component is going to
need some Styles so we can add style
sheet to the Imports as well
lastly let's add feather from at Expo
slash
Vector icons
now we can Define our component so we
say const
eye context
equals
then we have a set of parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
outside of this we need to export the
component so we say export
default
icon text
let's also set up our Styles before we
export the component
so we say const
styles
equals
style sheet
Dot
create
we then use some parentheses
and some curly braces
inside of the component let's say return
and we'll add some parentheses
next we'll add The View
so let's go back to our city component
we can copy the first instance of where
the feather icon and the text is used
together
so where feather and text are used
inside of the population wrapper
I'll copy the icon
and also the text
next I'll go back to the icon text
component
and paste this in here
so what props are going to need to be
defined for this component
I know I'm going to need to define the
icon name
and the color
and also the text
so we can set these props up now
I'll change the name inside the feather
element to use curly braces
and then I'll pass in icon name
I'll do the same with the color
and then I'll pass in icon color
then in the text also inside curly
braces
I'll say body
text
now inside the components parameters
let's add props
then at the top of the file we can
anticipate these and use some
destructuring
so we'll say const
then some curly braces
equals
props
inside of the curly braces
I'll add icon name
icon color
and body text
now let's go back to our city component
again
if we take a look at the styles used for
population text and write set text we
can see these Styles differ a bit
both use a font weight of bold but
everything else is different
so how are we going to go about handling
this
we can actually just pass these in as a
prop as well
so let's start with the commonality and
handle the Bold font weight first
so back in the icon text component in
the text
we'll say Style
equals
styles
Dot
text theme
then inside the style sheet we can add
the text theme attribute
we'll say font weight
of bold
now if we go back to our city component
we can remove the font weight of bold
from the population text
and then also the rise set text
the remaining styles for these pieces of
text will pass down to the child in a
prop called body text styles
so let's add this prop to the icon text
component
in the destructuring of the component
I'll add body text styles
now in the text
I'll change the style here to accept an
array
as we're going to be passing in multiple
Styles here
inside the array I'll then add body text
styles
great
so now we should all be set up to use
this component inside of the city
component
so let's start by updating the
population text section
so inside of the view I'll add the icon
text component
next our set icon name
and I'll set this to user
then I'll add icon color
and set this to red
I'll set body text
to be eight thousand
and then body text styles
to be styles
Dot
population text
so now I can delete the feather and text
elements here
we need to repeat these steps for the
sunrise and the sunset
so I start by adding the icon text
component at the top of the sunrise
I set icon name
to Sunrise
icon color
to White
and body text
to 10.
46.
am
then I'll set the body text styles to be
styles
Dot
write set text
so now I can remove the feather and text
elements for the sunrise
let's do this again for the sunset
so I add the icon text component again
I set the icon name to Sunset
icon color to white
and body text to 17.
P.M
then I'll set body textiles
to be styles
Dot
rise set text
now I can remove the feather and text
elements for the sunset again
let's save this and see where things are
at in the simulator
so when the simulator runs the app we
see our city screen with the same
components as before
this time though we have a shared
component for the icon and text so we
have less duplication in our code
it's really good to pay attention to
detail when you're working with your
code the layout for the text does not
look centered under the icon so we
should fix that let's go back to our
code
next
let's go back to the icon text component
we'll add a style attribute to the view
so we can make sure the items contained
within the view are aligned correctly so
I'll say Style
equals
styles
Dot
container
then I'll add this to the style sheet
inside of the Styles I'll say align
items
of Center
now if I go back to the city screen I'm
going to create some shared styles for
the population wrapper and the rise set
wrapper
in the style sheet I'll call this row
layout
inside of this I'll add Flex Direction
of row
and align items
of Center
I'll then remove these from the
population wrapper and also the Rye set
wrapper
next I'll add a raise to both of the
style props in the view elements
and then I can add in the row layout for
these
in the inputs of the component let's
remove the reference to feather as this
is now no longer needed
then let's do some destructuring for the
styles
so before the return in the component
I'll say const
then I use some curly braces
and then I'll say equals
styles
inside of the curly braces I'll add
container city name
City text
country name
population wrapper
population text
rice set wrapper
and Rise set text
and then I'll go ahead and remove all
the Styles and dots inside the render
where these are used
so now if we go back to the icon text
component I'll also do the same thing
here so before the return I'll say const
then I'll use some curly braces and then
I'll say equals Styles inside the curly
braces I'll add container and text theme
and then I'll also remove the Styles and
the dots where these were used inside of
the render
so now let's save this and view this
again in the simulator
everything now looks good
so the only screen we haven't yet looked
at in terms of refactoring is the
current weather screen
if we take a look at this component now
we can see there's a couple of instances
where there's a view which wraps two
pieces of text
I'm also going to extract these to be
their own component
and I'm going to call this component row
text
so inside of the components directory
let's start by creating the Rotex
component
once this is created we can navigate to
the component and set up our Imports
so I start by saying import
react
from
this component is going to need to use
View and text
so I'll say import
View
[Music]
text
from react native
we're also going to need to add some
Styles so I'll add the style sheet
inside of the Imports
now we can go ahead and Define the
component
so I say const
bro text
then I use an equal sign
some parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
outside of the curly braces I'll say
export
default
bro text
before the export I'll also set up the
styles
so I say const styles
equals
style sheet
Dot
create
I'll use a set of parentheses
and some curly braces
now inside of the components curly
braces I'll say return
and I'll use a set of parentheses
let's go back to the current weather and
select the first instance of what we
want to use in this component
so I'll select The View with the high
low wrapper and then also the text
contained inside of it
I'll go back to the Rotex component and
I'll paste this in
so I know I'm going to need two props
for each bit of text
so inside the first text
I'll remove the text that says hi
and then I use curly braces
and I'll add a prop called message one
inside the second bit of text I'll do
the same thing again
but this time I call this message too
I'm going to want to pass in props for
the styles for The View
and also for both pieces of text in The
View
so I'll say Styles equals and then I'll
add container styles
in the first text I'll say Style
equals message one styles
and in the second bit of text I'll say
Style
equals
message to styles
let's update the component parameters to
include props
and then we can also add our
destructuring to anticipate these props
so at the top of the component I say
const
then I use some curly braces
and then I say equals
styles
inside of the curly braces I'll add
message one
message to
container styles
message one styles
and message two styles
now let's go back to the current weather
component and update this to use our
Rotex component
so I'll start by adding row text just
before the view with the Hilo wrapper
next I'll set up our props
so I'll say message one
and I'll set this to high
colon
8.
next I'll say message two
and I'll set this equal to low
colon
six
our set container styles
to styles
Dot
high low wrapper
and then I'll set message one styles
to styles
Dot
Hilo
and message two styles
to styles
Dot
high low
now I can go ahead and delete the
existing View and text here
next Above The View with the body
wrapper I can follow these steps again
so I add the row text
and then I set up my props
so I say message one
and set this to it's sunny
next
I sent message two
and I set this to it's
perfect
t-shirt
weather
I then set container styles
and set this to be styles
Dot
body wrapper
and then I set message one styles
to styles
Dot
description
and message two styles
to styles
Dot
message
now I can go ahead and delete the
existing View and text here too
we need to make sure the Rotex component
has been imported at the top of the file
vs code has done this automatically for
me when I started using the component
next let's go back to our app.js file
and in the render let's update this to
show the current weather component now
let's run the app in the simulator and
see how everything looks
when the app runs in the simulator it
looks like something's broken
debugging errors is a really important
process to get to grips with when you're
working with your code
sometimes it's just figuring out how to
approach a problem as opposed to
panicking
so how do we know what the problem is
here
well we know the only components we have
changed are the city and Road tax
components
it's the Rotex component which is not
showing on our screen so let's take a
look at that first
the render looks okay
but when we destructured our props I set
this to Styles not props
so this looks like it'll be the cause of
our problems here
I'll change this from styles to props
also we aren't setting anything in our
style sheet so let's clean this up too
I'll remove the style declaration
and I'll also remove stylesheet from the
Imports as it turned out we didn't need
this after all
let's save this and view the app in the
simulator
everything now looks good
let's wrap up our refactoring by just
doing one last bit of Cleanup in the
current weather component
for consistency I'm going to add
destructuring to the styles used here
so I'll say const
then I use some curly braces
and then I'll say equals
styles
inside the curly braces I'll say wrapper
container
temp
fails
Hilo wrapper
high low
body wrapper
description
and message
then I'll go ahead and remove the Styles
and dots inside of the render function
let's save this and run the app in the
simulator again
now everything looks good and we have
fixed the issue with the row layout not
displaying
so now we're ready to go ahead and look
at wiring up our app with navigation
when you're building web apps you can
use anchor tags to link between the
different pages
if a user clicks on a link or a button
to navigate to a new page then that URL
gets pushed onto a stack which is
essentially a data structure and in this
case it will be called the browser
history stack
later when the user wants to navigate
back then the URL gets popped off the
stack and they're able to go back to the
prior page where they'd come from
when you use a mobile app it's quite
unusual these days that it will only
have one screen as they usually have
more information to show a user
however we can't use navigation in the
way that we do on the web so we need
some way to navigate between the
different screens in our application
in our app we have already built three
different screens we have a screen to
show the current weather
a screen to show the upcoming weather
and a screen to show the city details
in order to navigate between the screens
we need to use a navigator
you might have noticed this before but
the other consideration with navigation
is how the navigation between the
screens occurs
so by this I mean the transition
when you click something in an app to
load another screen does the next screen
then slide in from the right to the left
or does it perhaps drop down from the
top to the bottom
as well as all of this there's then the
different types of navigation to
consider because perhaps we want to use
tabs in the app to let the user navigate
around
in react native there's no built-in
navigation so you have to use a library
to add navigation to your app
the two most popular libraries are react
navigation
and react native navigation
while both of these libraries have the
same end goal the implementation of the
two differs
the other consideration between the two
libraries is that react navigation is
built into Expo
so if you created your app with Expo you
can use it just fine
however if you want to use react native
navigation you would have to eject your
app from Expo
or you would have had to create your app
without using Expo and I showed you how
to do this at the start of the course
so in our app we're going to be using
react navigation and our goal is to
implement tabs for the user to navigate
between our different screens
so let's start by installing react
navigation to do this in the terminal we
need to type npm
install
at
react
Dash
navigation
slash
native
next because we're using Expo we have
some additional dependencies we need to
install to get everything up and running
if you're not using Expo you can see the
additional installation steps required
to get up and running with react
navigation here
so for Expo we need to run npx
Vo
install
react
Dash
native
screens
react
Dash
native
safe
Dash
area
context
so once everything is installed we need
to set up a navigation container
this will wrap the entire application
and usually we'd only do this once in
the application and we do it at the root
of our project
so we're going to add this to the app.js
file
so
we start at the top of the file and we
say import
next we use curly braces
and we need to make sure we use a
capital N
and we say navigation container
and this is imported from at
react
Dash navigation
slash native
next inside the render at the top we
need to place a navigation container
then we close this at the very bottom of
the render so that it contains
everything
at the start of this section I discussed
how on the web we push and pop items off
of the stack
with react navigation we follow a
similar idea except that we do this via
a navigator
so the screens can get pushed and popped
off of the Navigator
there are two types of Navigators we can
use and this depends on our requirements
essentially if we don't want the user to
navigate to a screen using a tab then
probably we'll want to use the stack
Navigator
so let's look at some examples to show
this a bit more clearly if I load this
example on snack from the react
navigation website
I see a settings screen
if I click the button that says go to
profile
and then navigated to the profile screen
next
if I then click the back icon
the profile screen is popped off of the
navigation stack
and I'm back on the settings screen
for this kind of navigation you would
want to use a stack Navigator
at the bottom of the screen there are
also some tabs
when I select one of these the screen
the user sees changes
and this is the behavior I want for our
application
if you want to explore more deeply all
the kinds of navigation available to use
with react navigation then you can visit
this GitHub repository
and then you can navigate to the example
section
if you load this then you can play about
with everything
so for our app as I said we want to use
tabs to let the user navigate between
the different screens
it's up to you when you create your app
to decide where you want the tabs to
show as you can show them on the bottom
of the screen or the top of the screen
there are some platform considerations
to bear in mind here too as often on
Android you have tabs at the top of the
screen
and on iOS you have them at the bottom
in our app we're going to display the
tabs at the bottom of the screen
but if you wanted to show this on the
top for Android and the bottom for iOS
you would need to set up material top
tabs and then decide which to display
based on the platform
you can access the platform the user is
using by using the platform API from
react native
and then you can use the OS property
so back to our tabs
we need to start by installing the
bottom tabs so we say npm install
at react navigation
slash
bottom tabs
once this is done if we go back to our
app.js file we can import this
so underneath the import for the
navigation container we say import
then we use curly braces
and inside the curly braces we say
create bottom tab Navigator
and then we say from
at react navigation
slash bottom tabs
next before the component is defined we
need to say const
then using a capital T
we say tab
equals
and then we say create bottom
tab Navigator
and follow this with parentheses
by doing this we're initializing the tab
object so that we can use it
next we want to wrap all our components
inside of the tab Navigator
so inside the navigation container
we say tab
Dot
Navigator
and then we close this just before the
closing navigation container
so next we're ready to go ahead and add
our screens
so I say tab
Dot
screen
and then I set the component name
so I say name
equals
and as a string I add the component name
and so the first one for us will be
current
and next I add the component
so I say component
equals
and then I set this to current weather
then I repeat this again for the other
two screens
so I say tab
Dot
screen
and then I set the component name which
is upcoming
and I set the component
to upcoming weather
lastly
I say tab
dot screen
and this time I set the name to be City
and I also set the component to be City
so now we should have just set up the
three screens for our app
let's save this and see what things are
looking like in the simulator
when the simulator runs the app we see a
screen with an error
the error says a screen can only contain
screen group or react fragment as its
direct children
so clearly we made an error here
the only file we've changed directly is
the app.js file so let's go back to that
file and take a look
so when we set up our tabs we did not
remove the view container
this is neither a screen group or react
fragment
so let's remove that
I'll remove the view
then in order to keep things tidy I'll
remove the view from the react native
Imports
I can also remove the styles that were
used for this
there are no other styles set now so
let's also remove the stylesheet
Declaration
and then also the import for style sheet
let's save this and run the app in the
simulator again
this time the app loads and I can see
the three tabs set up when I click
through the tabs I'm able to navigate to
the different screens on our app
it doesn't look very pretty though so
we'll go ahead and start looking at how
to make this look a bit better
so there's lots of configuration options
available to us with react navigation
as we can see here in the documentation
we can set a tab bar icon
if we look a bit more deeply into the
documentation you can see there's a
wealth of other things available too
so we can set labels and positions and
so on
in our app we already have the name
showing on the tabs for the different
screens but we're going to customize
things a bit further
we're going to set an active and an
inactive color for the tab bar
then we're also going to set icons for
each of the tab bar items
as we can see in the documentation we
set the active and inactive tint colors
on the Navigator
and then we set the icons in the tab
so back in our code in the tab Navigator
we're going to say screen options
then we'll use an equal sign
and some curly braces
inside the curly braces we use another
set of curly bracers
and then we say tab bar active
tint color
we're going to set this to the string
tomato
next we'll say tab bar inactive tint
color
and we'll set this to be Gray
for the tab icons we're going to use
some icons again from feather and Expo
icons
so we'll start by importing this at the
top of our file
we say import
then we use some curly braces
and inside the curly braces we say
feather
then we say from at Expo
slash Vector icons
so to set the Taber icon we can use the
tab bar icon property
as it says in the documentation we can
use it on our screen components in the
options prop
although for their example they've
placed it in the screen options prop of
the tab Navigator
in our implementation we'll be using it
in the screen components options
so in the first screen I say options
then I use an equal sign
and then I use two curly braces
next I say tab bar icon
and for the parameter I'm going to pass
in focused
this is because we're going to want to
set a different color for the icon
depending on whether the tab bar icon is
or is not selected
next
I use an arrow
and then some parentheses
inside the parentheses I'll render the
feather icon
so I just say feather
I've already selected the icons for the
tabs here so I'll say name
equals
and inside curly braces I'll set this to
be droplets
our set size
to 25
and inside color
if the icon is focused we want to return
tomato
otherwise we want to return black
now we need to repeat these steps again
for our other two screens
so in the screen of the upcoming weather
I say options
then an equal sign
and two curly braces
next I say tab bar icon
and for the parameter I pass in focused
then I use an arrow
and some parentheses
next I set up the feather icon
this time for name
I set it to be clock
I'll set size to 25
and for the color
I'll say if focused
then show tomato
otherwise
show black
then for the city screen we do this
again
so I say options
and I use the two curly braces
inside of the curly braces I then set
the feather icon up
I set name
to home
size
to 25 and for the color I say if it's
focused
use tomato
otherwise
use black
so now the tab icons and styling should
be set up
let's save everything and see where
things are at in the simulator
so back in the simulator we see all of
our tabs set up with the tabs and the
icons
everything should now be running
correctly
in order to make our code a bit easier
to follow I'm going to extract the tabs
into their own component and then I'll
import this into the app.js file
so inside the components directory we'll
create a file called tabs.js
next back in the app.js component I'm
going to copy all the Imports and the
initialization of the tabs
then I'll paste this into the tabs file
now I can go ahead and create the
component
so I say const tabs
equals
then a set of parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
inside the curly braces I'll say return
and I'll use some parentheses
outside of the component I'll say export
default tabs
now I'll go back to the app.js file and
I'll copy everything related to the tabs
next I'll paste this into the tabs.js
file
back in the app.js file we can now
delete all the code related to the tabs
now if I go back to the tabs component
I need to update all the Imports for my
screens as we're now inside of a
directory and not at the root of the
project
back in the app.js file I can then
delete all the Imports which are now not
needed
lastly in the render I can just pass in
the tabs component
so now everything's much more readable
let's save this and view it in the
simulator
thing looks good and we see the tabs in
the simulator still
when I click on a tab it changes color
and our tab code is extracted into its
own component so everything is nice and
tidy
if we go back to the code for the tabs
component you may see an eslint warning
I'm going to just disable this warning
for this file as we need to follow the
react navigation requirements and set up
our tabs in this way
so before we move on let's add a few
more customization details to our
navigation
in the header bar I get the same name as
I do for the tab name so we don't need
to change this but I'm going to set the
background color of the tab bar and also
the background color of the header bar
after that I'll go ahead and add some
more styles to the font used in the
header bar
so in my screen options for the tab
Navigator
I'll say tab bar Style
and then I'll use an object
inside of this I'll say background color
and I'll set this to light blue
this is all one word and all lowercase
next I'll set another property called
header Style
and I'll also use an object here
I'll set the background color
also to light blue
then I'll set a property called header
title Style
and I'll also use an object for this
inside of this object I'll say font
weight
of bold
font size
of 25
and color
to be tomato let's save this and check
things out in the simulator
so now we can see our tab bar and header
bar
both have a matching background color
the font in the header bar is a bit
larger and bolder and the color of the
selected tab matches the color of the
header bar title
there's a ton of customization options
available to you with react navigation
so I strongly advise you spend some time
getting familiar with the documentation
you can see a bit more about the header
bars here
so we're shortly going to move on and
look at State and then data fetching in
our app
after that we'll look at using the real
data in our components
in order to prepare ourselves for this
though there's one more file I'd like to
implement
in our current weather component we
currently have an icon and a message
description set for when the weather is
sunny
in the completed app we're going to show
a different icon and a different message
based on the weather
additionally we're going to change the
background color of the screen to
represent the different weather
we'll base these different states on the
weather conditions provided by the open
weather map API
so we're going to create a file which
contains these conditions and then the
icons message and background color which
should be shown for these conditions
so we'll start by creating a directory
to store this which will be called
utilities
so let's do that now
in the SRC directory we'll create a new
directory called utilities
then we'll call the file which will
store these properties and values
weather type
inside the file we need to create an
object
so we say export const
weather type
and then we set that equal to an object
because of the data provided by the API
we need to capitalize the weather types
we'll start by creating the objects for
each of the weather types
the first one is called thunderstorm
the next is drizzle
then we set rain
next we'll set snow
then clear
clouds
Haze
and mist
so let's start by setting up the
thunderstorm type
we'll set an icon
and give this the value of the string
zap
next we'll set a message
and we'll set this to the string
it could
get
noisy
and then we'll set a background color
to the black hex color value of zero
zero zero
zero zero zero
note that this is passed in as a string
so the next one is drizzle
this one will have an icon
of cloud
Dash
brain
then for the message we'll say it might
rain
a little
then we set the background color
to 364
f
for rain we'll set the icon to Umbrella
and then for the message we'll say you
will need
an umbrella
and the background color will be zero
zero zero
0 f f
for snow we'll set the icon to Cloud
Dash
snow
for the message we'll say let's build
a
Snowman
and the background color will be set to
7 F6
zero six five
next for Clear we'll set the icon
to Sun
and we'll set the message to
it is
perfect
t-shirt
weather
and the background color will be set to
e47
two
zero zero
now for clouds we'll set the icon
to Cloud
we'll set the message
to you could
live in
the clouds
and then the background color will be
set to 363
now for haze
we'll set the icon
to wind
and the message will say
it might be
a bit damp
and then for the background color
we'll set this to 585
8 6 e
and then lastly for mist
we'll set the icon
to align
Dash
ify
the message will be set to
it might
be hard
to see
and then the background color will be
set to 3e3
e37
[Music]
right that was a lot of typing
but now we can try this out even though
we don't have any real data yet being
used
if we go back to the current weather
component we can start by importing this
file
as we're not importing a component but
we're importing an exported object we
need to use curly braces
so we say import
and then we use curly braces
inside the curly braces we say weather
type
and then we import this from utilities
weather type
so let's test this out on the weather
condition message
so inside the last row text component
inside the message to prop
we can just say weather type
and then use square brackets
and let's try out the message for the
Thunder weather condition
so as we're using square bracket
notation here we pass in the string
let's save this and see what things look
like in the simulator
so now we're going to move on to some of
the more deeper topics in react native
and we're going to take a step back from
our app just for a bit in order to take
the time to learn some of the details
required to successfully make our app
more dynamic
Dynamic is the key word here
so far in our application everything has
been static
this means that we have all our screens
and all of these are now wired up with
navigation
but nothing in our app really does
anything except display values to the
user which we have hard-coded in
ourselves
if this is all you wanted to do then you
only need to use props just like we have
and you can pass your data around from
parent to child components
but isn't the real excitement of making
applications these days how interactive
we can make them and how fun we can make
the experience for the user
when was the last time you enjoyed using
an application either on the web or on
mobile that only functioned in this way
with react native and react we're able
to make the user experience super
interactive and update and respond to
users input
so given this intention props are only
half of the story
the other half is state
is what I'm going to introduce you to
now
so what is state
to put it simply state is an object and
this object contains data about the
component that for some reason we decide
we need to keep track of within our
application
in the object we Define key value Pairs
and these key value pairs are the way in
which we track a single piece of data
that over time is going to change
let's visualize this a bit more
if we go back to the house example from
when we looked at props
using the props we pass data down to
each of the rooms in the house
using State though we can be inside a
room and keep track of something that is
going to change in the room
so perhaps we want to keep track of the
messy state
or maybe we want to keep track of
whether the room was dark so we could
track the value dark as true or false
or maybe we know a massive storm is
incoming so we want to keep track of
whether or not the room is wet
the benefit of state within a react
native or react application is that it
means things can change
they can be added
modified
and removed
and we as the developer can work with
this more easily and update our internal
data and Trigger UI updates based on
these changes
there is one very key point to be aware
of here though
when the data in our component changes
the component will re-render
so to emphasize this point when a
component first renders on the screen to
the user we have what is called an
initial render
if we're using State and some of this
state changes
then the component will re-render itself
so let's look at this through our room
example when the storm is possibly
incoming
our room component renders on the screen
when it first loads
we have a wet State and this is set to
force
later the storm happens
our room gets flooded
this causes the wet state to get set to
true
consequently the room component then
re-renders
in the world of coding this sort of
change might be more likely to occur
based on a user event such as a button
press or perhaps some sort of user input
such as typing something into an input
field
it's totally fine if this all seems a
bit overwhelming or confusing right now
it can be a lot of information to
process
let's stop for a moment and summarize
what we have just learned
we have learned the state as an object
that is used to keep track of data about
a component
we've learned that by using State we can
add remove or modify things in our
component more easily
and then we can trigger UI updates based
on these changes
additionally we've also learned that
when State changes it causes the
component to re-render
so let's just be very clear now on the
difference between props and State
props let us pass data between the
components where a state lets us
internally manage the data within a
component
you therefore can't modify the state of
the component outside of the component
in this sense it's a bit like when
you're working with local scope in
JavaScript
of course with vanilla JavaScript you
can make things Dynamic but the benefit
of working with react native and react
is that a lot of the hard work is done
for you
and you just have to provide initial
values and then consider how you would
like this value to update and then also
be displayed to the user
if and when your state grows you need
this to be at an application Level then
you can also access libraries to help
you manage this such as Redux
but that is out of the scope of this
course so we're going to continue our
journey with state by creating a simple
counter component which won't be in our
final app but will hopefully solidify
our understanding a bit more here
we'll start by creating the component
without using state so hopefully we can
better see why we need State and then
we'll add state to the component
so inside the SRC directory I'm going to
create a new directory called
demonstration
you're welcome to keep the code in this
directory for reference purposes or
delete it in the final project at the
end of the course
but it saves us from having to create a
new app for any demonstration code which
we'll make during the rest of the course
so in the SRC folder let's create this
new folder called demonstration
now inside of this folder I'm going to
create a component called counter.js
we'll set this up just like we have with
our other components
so we'll start by importing react from
react
next we'll import View
text
button
and style sheet
and we'll import these from react native
now let's go ahead and create the
component
hopefully you're getting used to doing
this now
but we'll start by saying const
counter
and we'll follow this by an equal sign
some parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
outside of the curly braces we'll export
the component
so we say export default
counter
inside of the curly braces
will say return
and we'll use a set of parentheses
then before the export we'll create our
style sheet so we say const styles
equals
style sheet dot create
and then we use some parentheses
and some curly braces
so let's set up our component
before the return I'm going to create a
variable which will store the value of
count
so I say let count
and I set this equal to zero
now inside of the return we can create a
view
then we'll also create some text
inside of the text we're going to use a
template literal and interpolate in the
count value
so we use curly braces
and then some backticks
we say count
and a colon
then we pass in the count variable
next we'll add two buttons
for the first button
will set color
to red
for the title
will say increase the count
and then we set on press
for this we use an array function so we
use some parentheses
and an arrow
for the first one I'm actually going to
use curly braces because there's a
little bit more I want to do here
so firstly I'll increment the count
so I say count plus plus
and then I also want to add a console
log to print out the value of the count
variable
for the second button we'll set the
color to Green
for the title we'll say decrease the
count
and for onpress I'll just pass in an
arrow function
which will decrement the count
let's add a couple of styles
on The View we'll set a container so I
say style equals Styles Dot
container
and for the text I'll set some Styles
called title
so I say styles
equals
styles
Dot
title
in the style sheet I'll set the
container
I'll give this Flex of one
and background color
of Orange
next I'll set the title
I'll give this a line south of Center
and font size of 25.
and then I'm going to set a margin top
of 25.
we also need to be able to see this
component on the screen of our app
so let's go back to our app.js file
I'm going to start by importing the
counter
and I'll do this from dot slash
SRC
slash demonstration
slash
counter
temporarily I'm going to remove the tabs
from the render in the component and
replace this with the counter
now let's load the simulator
we now see our counter component on the
screen
we see the two buttons
and also the text which displays the
counter value
great
so let's now click the button to
increment the counter
so it looks like the button was pressed
successfully but the count value has not
updated on the screen
let's dig into this bit more and we'll
check the Contour log we added
so it looks like this did increment
I'll press the increase button again
we now see two
so the counter value is definitely
increasing
but the text that displays the count on
the screen is not showing the correct
count
so the reason for this is that react
does not re-render a component when the
value of a variable changes
if this happened we would end up with
re-renders happening all over the place
and it would result in a really bad user
experience
I mentioned when we looked at state that
when we use State and the state changes
the component re-renders
so this is a great example of a use case
for state
we'll look more deeply at hooks in a bit
but we're going to use a hook provided
by react called you state in order to
fix our problems here
for now you can think of a hook as
functions that we can use inside of our
function components
all of the components we have made
throughout this course have been
function components
so to start off we need to import the
use date hook
we do this when we import react
so in the react import we add a comma
and then some curly braces
inside of the curly braces we say you
state
now when any values we use with the
u-state hook are updated then react will
ensure the component also gets updated
to reflect these changes to the user
so now we need to update the Declaration
for our count variable and use the use
State hook instead
so let's delete the variable and we'll
start again
this time we use the hook
so we say const
and then we use square brackets
and we say equals
use state
inside the square brackets I'll say
count
and then set count
lastly inside the parentheses for the U
state
I'll set the value 0.
so when we use the use date hook we're
setting up some piece of State for our
component
when you state is set up we need to pass
in the initial value for what the state
should be
so if we were implementing the flooded
room example here we might have to set
this up by saying is flooded
and set is flooded
and then in the parentheses we would
have said false for the initial value
we want the counter to start at zero
which is why here we're passing in zero
we can pass in any of the data types
required for our needs though so this
could also be a string or an object and
so on
the square brackets where we have added
count and set count are simply using a
ready structuring
the first value in this is the count and
this tracks the value for the count
but we never directly change the value
of count instead we use set count which
is a function
and into this we pass what we want the
new value for count to be
so let's go ahead and update our
component to use this
in the first button I'm going to remove
the console log
and also the incrementing of the old
count variable
then I will say set count
and it will pass in count
plus one
so we aren't modifying count here we're
just getting the value of count and then
adding one to it
in the second button I'll say set count
and this time I'll pass in the value of
count again
and then minus one
let's save this and go back to the
simulator
now let's press the increase button
the count displayed on the screen
updates to show our new count now let's
press the button to decrement the value
the value on the screen now decrements
so now we have successfully worked with
State for the first time
let's recap what we have just learned
when we want to use you state in a
function component we can use a hook
called you state
we never directly change the value for
the state but we can update it buyer a
function that enables us to update the
state
we use array structuring for the u-state
hook
and inside this we have the value for
the state and then the function we use
to update the state and inside this we
have the value for the state
and then also a function that we can use
to update the state
inside the parentheses a view State we
also set the initial or default value
for the state
before we move on in the last section I
introduced you to Hooks and I want to go
over these in a bit more detail
and then I'm going to move on to showing
you another hook which will help us with
our data fetching
back in the older days of using react
and react native in the most part we had
two types of components that we could
use
these were called stateful
and state less
if we wanted our component to use state
in some way we would create a stateful
component
if we did not need to use state in our
component then we could use a stateless
component
a stateful component was a class and the
Syntax for a class component looks like
this
we can still create class components in
react day so they're worth knowing about
and you may very well come across an
older code that uses them
when you use class components you can
access what are called lifecycle methods
lifecycle methods are essentially events
that occur during the life cycle of a
component
it's a little bit like key events that
occur during the life of a human
a human gets born
they have an annual birthday
and later in their life they pass away
when a component is created it is
mounted and the lifecycle method for
this event is called component did Mount
when the component updates another
lifecycle method is called which is
named should component update
and this lets you control when the
component should re-render
just before the component is destroyed
another lifecycle method is invoked core
component will unmount
when you're using a class you can tap
into these methods and during these
events you can add some additional
functionality
if you want to read more about lifecycle
methods you can find some details here
as react has evolved there's been a
tendency to move away from using class
components
and these days function components are
favored
when components were either stateful or
state less this wasn't very practical
but in react 16.8 hooks were introduced
hooks provide us with a way to use the
features we depended on classes for like
State and life cycle methods but from
inside of our function components
you can think of hooks like special
functions or pieces of reusable logic
which are separate from our component
tree
but that let us add functionality to our
function components
when we use hooks we can isolate all the
logic from the component in a readable
way
but we can use them within our component
you can read more about hooks here
every hook in react starts with the word
use
and we've just seen an example of this
when we looked at the use statehook
there are a couple of rules you should
be aware of when you're using hooks
though
firstly you can only call hooks from
react functions like our functional
components you can't just use them
wherever inside normal JavaScript
functions
additionally hooks must be called at the
top level of a component and before the
return keyword is used
we'll see more about this later but
aside from react hooks you can also
create your own hooks and these hooks
can call other hooks
we're going to move on now to
introducing ourselves to another Hook
from react could use effect
after this we'll return back to our app
and start looking at data fetching
the use effect Hook is extremely
powerful
but it can also seem quite overwhelming
when you're first looking at it
if you can understand how to use the use
effect hook properly then you can do all
sorts of things with your application
let's start by looking at the
documentation
so it says the effect hook lets you
perform side effects in function
components
the example also goes on to state that
it's similar to component did Mount and
component did update
let's break this down a bit
to start with what is a side effect
well it's when we use something not
inside of react within our component so
examples of these sorts of things are
fetching data using timer functions and
updating the Dom directly
we also know that component did Mount
happens when the component is first
mounted
and component did update is called after
updating occurs
so use effect essentially lets us
replicate these lifecycle methods and it
means we can perform side effects like
fetching data
from within our function components
so let's go ahead and look at the basic
Syntax for the use effect hook
if we look carefully we can see that use
effect takes in a function as an
argument
and it's inside of this that we can
write our side effects
let's add the use effect hook to our
counter example so we can understand
things a bit more deeply
so inside the counter component next to
the use date import we need to start by
also importing use effect
next under the u-state hook we can use
use effect
so we say use effect
and then we pass in a function
now inside the function let's add a
console log for the count
so I say Contour log
and then inside this I'm going to use
backticks
and then I'll say our count value is
and then I will interpolate in the value
of count
now let's see this in action in our
simulator
I'll start by reloading the screen
so now in the console log I see the
initial value of count printed to the
screen
every time I click one of the buttons as
the component is re-rendering here I see
the new value of count printed to the
screen too
so we could be doing anything in here
that we want to happen as soon as the
component first renders such as fetching
some data
right now we're also repeating the code
inside of here every time that the
component re-renders
if we take a look at the react docs
again we can see that use effect also
takes one other parameter called
dependencies
which it compares to the lifecycle
method component did update
it says on the documentation that you
can tell it to skip applying an effect
if certain values have not changed
between renders
to do so you pass an array as an
optional second argument to use effect
so to summarize this a bit inside of
this array we pass in all of the values
that the side effect inside of use
effect relies on
in our example we're console logging
based on the value of the count
so we need to include count inside of
the dependencies array
this now means that the code inside of
use effect will only run if that value
has changed between renders
if we do not pass in the dependencies
array then the code inside of use effect
will run after every render
let's look at this in our demonstration
I'm actually going to add two new
buttons to the component
I'll just copy and then paste the first
two buttons
next I'll create another count and set
count with a new use date hook
I'll call the state variable here new
count
and then for the function to update the
state I'll call it set new count
and then I'll update the on press inside
of the new buttons to call set new count
so now inside of the use effect I'm
going to change the console log to just
be count changed
let's run this in the simulator
when the screen loads I get count
changed printed to the console every
time I press any of the buttons I see
the count change console log printed to
the screen again so now let's go back to
our code and we're going to pass in a
dependency array inside of the
dependency array I'm going to pass in
count now let's run this again in the
simulator
so I get the console log printed to the
console when the screen launches
this time though
I only see this printed of screen again
when I click on any of the first two
buttons which use count
I don't however see it printed to the
screen when I press any of the buttons
that use new count
so the effect only runs when count
changes otherwise it just sits there and
it doesn't do anything again
the last thing you need to be aware of
when you are using use effect relates to
the component we'll unmount lifecycle
method
and it's called the cleanup function
this cleanup function allows us to turn
off or clean up our side effects
so for example if you're using a counter
we would need to use the clear interval
function to stop the counter and this is
where we would place that and by doing
so we can avoid memory leaks
to use a cleanup function we type return
and then we use an arrow function
followed by the cleanup we would like to
perform
we can see an example of this on the
react documentation again
as the documentation says react performs
the cleanup when the component unmounts
so we don't really have any cleanup we
need to do in our example but I'm going
to add a console log here to show how
this works
so back inside of our code and inside of
the use effect
I will say return and then I use some
parentheses an arrow
and some curly braces
then I'll just Contour log a string
which says use effect
clean up
let's save this and go back to the
simulator
now when I click one of the buttons
which triggers a re-render I also get
the console log for the cleanup log to
the screen because the cleanup is called
before the next use effect runs
so before we move back to our app let's
do a bit of recapping about everything
we've just learned with use effect
we have learned that use effect is a
hook provided by react which lets us run
code that has side effects
we've seen that it takes a function with
the code to run
then we saw that you can also pass in a
dependency array which lets you specify
what data when changed that you would
like to trigger a re-render
lastly we looked at the cleanup function
that we can use with use effect to run
any cleanup and stop any of the side
effects before use effect is called upon
a new render and when the component is
unmounted
so now we have some understanding around
Hooks and use State and use effect
so we're ready to go back to our app and
think about our next steps with our
weather application
so back in our app we have a few things
that we're going to do now in order to
make the app dynamic
to start off inside the app.js file I'm
going to reset the code to use the tabs
inside the render
and I'm also going to delete the import
for the counter
I'm going to break down the next steps
we need to achieve
the first thing we're going to do is
Implement a loading state for when the
app first launches and the data is being
fetched this is so the user sees
something during this process
it's always good when you're making
applications to consider all the various
loading and error states that the user
might encounter
after this we're going to look at
fetching the data from the open weather
map API and this will be broken down
into two parts
getting the user's location and then
fetching the data
so let's start first with the loading
state
as I mentioned we want to start the app
in the loading State until the data from
the open weather map API is successfully
fetched
once it is fetched we'll set the loading
state to false and navigate the user
onto our weather related components
for our loading State we want to display
to the user a spinner
instead of having to manually create
this react native has a core component
that does this for us it's called
activity indicator
let's have a look at the documentation
so we can see the activity indicator
displays a circular loading indicator to
the user and we can customize the size
and the color of the spinner
on the documentation we can see a few of
the activity indicators in action with
the different sizes and colors set
so let's go back to our app and we'll
start to set this up
so inside the app.js file we'll start by
importing the activity indicator
after the react import I'll say import
then I'll use some curly braces
and inside the curly braces I'll say
Activity indicator
and I'll import this from react native
next in order to set the loading State
we're going to use U state
so in the react import I add a comma
some curly braces
and then inside the curly braces I say
use state
now this is imported we need to set up
you state
so before the return inside of the ACT
component I say const
I use some square brackets
and then I say you state
with some parentheses
I'm going to call this piece of State
loading
so inside the square brackets I'll add
I'm going to call the function to update
the state set loading
so I'll add this too
then I'm going to set the initial state
for our loading State as true
this means when the app first launches
the user will see the activity indicator
then once the data is fetched we can set
this to force and then they'll see the
weather components
so now in the render we need to have a
way to say if the state is loading then
show the activity indicator otherwise
show the tabs
there are a few ways we can Implement
conditional rendering in react and react
native
knowing about if else statements ternary
operators and also the logical and
operator is useful when it comes to
handling these scenarios and you can
read more about these here
in our case for now we're going to keep
this very straightforward and just use
an if statement which renders the
activity indicator when the loading
state is true
if the loading state is not true then
the navigation container and the tabs
will be rendered
so inside of our app component I'm going
to say if loading
then inside the parentheses here I'll
say return
and inside the return I'm going to add a
view
and then also the activity indicator
so we're wrapping the activity indicator
inside of a view here so we can better
control the layout for it
for our activity indicator we're going
to say size equals
and then we'll set this to the string
large
and we're also going to set the color
so we say color equals
and then we set this to the string blue
we also want to set a couple of styles
for the view just so we're sure we're
setting the layout for the activity
indicator to be in the center of the
screen
so in the view I say style equals
styles
Dot
container
now in the react native Imports we need
to add the view and the style sheet
before the component is exported let's
set up the style sheet so I say const
Styles equals stylesheet Dot
create
and then I pass in the object
I'm going to set the container
and for this I'm going to say justify
content
of Center
and flex
of one
let's save this and see how it looks in
the simulator
when the simulator runs I see the
loading spinner in the center of the
screen
if the loading state was set to false I
would see the tabs and our weather
screens
so next we're finally ready to look at
getting data from the API
so in order to get data from the open
weather map API we need to start by
calling the API
let's take a look back at the API
documentation on the open weather map
website
for our app we want to display the
current weather
but also the upcoming weather
so we're going to use the five day three
hour forecast
if I click on the API documentation here
it shows us how to make the API cool
as we can see there are a few things
that are required to make this
successfully
we will need the latitude and the
longitude which a geographical
coordinates for where we want to display
the data from
and then we're also going to need our
API key
let's start by figuring out how we'll
get the latitude and the longitude
the technical term for finding
Geographic data such as coordinates is
geolocation
if I search for react native geolocation
we can see that this has been deprecated
and we should use one of the community
packages instead
if I click on the link we can see that
there are a variety of packages
available
so this is useful if you did not create
the app with Expo and it's also
something to know about in the future
but as we created the app with Expo
we're able to use a package called Expo
location
let's take a look at the documentation
for this
so as it says Expo location allows
reading geolocation information from the
device
this sounds exactly what we're looking
for
let's start by installing it
so in our terminal we need to say npx
Expo
install
Dash
location
now if we go back to the documentation
we can see all the extra configuration
and then there's also steps provided if
you're installing the project in a bear
react native project
in the example provided we see that we
have to complete two steps in order to
get the user's location
firstly we have to ask for permission to
access their location
and then we need to get their location
once we have their location we need to
store this
we also need to be mindful of handling
any errors in case we were not able to
access the user's location
so for implementing this successfully
we're going to need to use you state in
order to store the location and any
errors and then we're also going to need
use effect
so back in our code let's start by
importing use effect
next we'll set up two pieces of State
we'll do the location first
so we say const
then we use square brackets
and we say equals
use state
inside the square brackets we'll say
location
and then set location
we're going to initialize this with null
now for the error we need to set up
another piece of State
so we say const then we use square
brackets
and we set this equal to U state
this time in the square brackets we'll
say error
and set error and then we'll initialize
this with null
next let's set up the use effect
so before the return we say use effect
and then into this we need to pass a
function
we're going to pass in a function which
needs to be immediately invoked so
inside of the curly braces we use a set
of parentheses
next we say async
this is so that JavaScript knows we're
using an asynchronous function here
then we can set this up as a function so
we use parentheses
an arrow and some curly braces
inside the curly braces we say let then
use curly braces
and we set this equal to
await
location
Dot
request
foreground
permissions
async
make sure you capitalize the location
here
we want to access the status so inside
the curly brackets we're going to place
status
next we handle the error using an if
statement
so we say if
status
does not strictly equal
granted
then we use our set error State function
and we set this to the string
permission
to access location
was denied
and then we say return
now outside of the if statement we can
continue with the rest of the code for
if the request for permissions were
successful
so we create a variable using let called
location
we assigned to this await
Dot
get current position
async
into this we pass in an empty object
lastly all we need to do is update the
location
so we say set location
and into this we pass in the location
then as we want to immediately invoke
this at the end of the function we use a
set of parentheses
inside of the use effect we'll pass in
an empty array for the dependencies
this means there's no dependencies and
that use effect will only run once when
the component is first rendered
in our component we're just going to add
a console log for now
and we'll say if location
then console log location
before we test this we need to ensure
location is enabled on the simulator or
emulator
you can see more information about how
to do this in the documentation here
let's go ahead and test this out in the
simulator
when the simulator runs we see the
permission request which we set up
when I click on allow while using the
app
and then launch the console
I then get to see the location data
which includes the latitude and
longitude which we were looking for
it's worth knowing here as a side note
that when you're using a simulator the
location defaults to San Francisco as
opposed to your real location
so now we have this let's look at
getting data from the API
at this point it would be helpful if
you're signed in on the open weather map
API website
thank you
to start with I'm going to navigate back
to the five day three hour forecast
and then I'll open the documentation
here
next I'm going to copy and paste the URL
for the API call
that we're going to need as we're going
to need that shortly
for now I'll just paste this at the top
of the app.js file
so we need to think about how in the app
we're going to store the API key
it's always best practice and safer not
to expose any secrets in your
application and import them from an
external place
this is even more important if you're
using Source control like GitHub because
you don't want these keys to be visible
to anyone
there are a few ways you can go about
doing this and there's some deeper
documentation on the Expo site here if
you would like to find out more about
this
for our example we're going to use a
package called react native.enth
this means we can use an environmental
variable where the value is set from
outside of the application
so let's go ahead and set this up
so we need to start by installing it
back in our terminal we'll say npm
install
d
react
native
dot ends
once this is installed we need to go to
our Babel config file and then add the
plugin
so after presets we need to add a comma
and then for the key we say plugins
and then we use an array
inside of this as a string we say module
colon
react
Dash
native
dot end
so now we can create the dot end file
so at the root of the project I'm going
to create a file called dot ends
once this is done we can test this out
I'm just going to use a dummy value for
now using capitals which is the best
convention
so first I'll set the name of the key to
be test
underscore
key
then I'll say equals
and for this I'll just say one two three
now if I go back to the app.js file I
can import this
so in my input I say import
then I use curly braces
and I say from
at NF
inside the curly braces I place the name
of my key
which was test underscore
key
so now I'll just add a console log with
this
let's save this and run the app in the
simulator
when the simulator runs if I check the
console I can see the value of the key
printed successfully
so we've proven the package was
successfully set up let's go back to our
app
as I'm using git I want to make sure the
dot end file is not pushed so inside the
git ignore I will add the file name
this means it will not be part of any
committing and pushing to get that I do
so next let's go back to the dot end
file
we'll delete the test key
and we'll add our key for the open
weather map API
I'll call this key weather
underscore API
underscore
key
the next thing we're going to need to do
is to get the API key
so back on the open weather map website
as long as you're signed in you can
click on your user
and then my API keys
on this screen you can copy and paste
the key if you have one
otherwise you can generate one by
selecting generate and then copy and
paste it
if you now go back to your Dot N file
you can paste it in
and then we should be good to go
so the last bit of setup we need to do
here if we go back to the app.js file we
can change the import for the test key
to be weather API key
now we can look at how we're going to
fetch the data
so to fetch the data we're going to use
the fetch API which is what react native
provides us with to work with networking
if you haven't used this before you can
read more about it here
and also here
so back in our app.js file we're going
to start by creating a new piece of
state to store the weather data
hopefully you're becoming more familiar
with this now but we'll say const
then we'll use a set of square brackets
and we'll set this equal to use state
we'll call this weather
so let's add that into the square
brackets
then we'll call the function to update
the state set weather
we'll initialize this as an empty array
so next we're going to encapsulate this
data fetching inside of a new function
which we'll call fetch weather data
so before the use effect we'll say const
fetch weather data
and we'll use an equal sign
and then async
next we'll use some parentheses
and arrow
and some curly braces
so now inside the curly braces we can
then set the response
so to start we declare a variable using
const called res
and to this we'll say await
fetch
and some parentheses
inside the parentheses we can paste in
the URL we want to fetch the data from
so we're going to use backticks here as
we're going to need to interpolate in
our environment variable
so we'll say http
colon
and two forward slashes
next we can paste in the URL that we
commented out earlier
we'll update these values shortly
so next we need to create another
variable to get the Json data
so we'll say const
data
and we'll assign to this await
response
Dot
Json
once we have this we can call our set
weather State function
so we say set weather
and into this we pass data
also once this is done we can set the
loadings date to be false
so we say set loading
and pass in false
then inside of the use effect after the
location is set we can say
await
fetch weather data
so let's now format the URL that we
passed into fetch
so inside curly braces we have the
latitude and longitude and also the API
key
so to start with we need to get the
latitude from our location piece of
State
so we say location
Dot
coords
latitude
and then we can do the same for the
longitude
so we say location
Dot
coords
longitude
now where the API key is we can pass in
our weather API key
we also need to make sure we're using
interpolation here so we need to add
dollar symbols before each of the curly
braces
foreign
there's also some error handling we need
to do here so if the response fails in
some way we can set our error state
to achieve this I'm going to wrap
everything inside of a try catch
statement
so I say try
then I use some curly braces
and then I say catch
and I place error inside of the
parentheses
then I use another set of curly braces
so inside the try I will place
everything we've written
and then inside of the catch I'll say
set error
and then inside parentheses I'll use a
string
and for this I'll say could not
fetch weather
additionally I'm going to use finally
here
this is used to execute something after
the try catch has been completed
so I'll say finally
and I use another set of curly braces
here I'm going to move set loading from
the try statement into here
the reason I'm doing this is so that we
have either the data or the error
once either of these is set we can set
loading to false and then we can
navigate to the correct screen for this
state of course this also means we're
going to need to add a screen to show
the user if there is an error but we'll
add that a bit later
so there's one last bit of refactoring I
want to do now when we initially set up
the location we set one piece of
location and then pulled out the
required values in the API call
I'm going to update this so we have two
separate pieces of State one for the
latitude and one for the longitude so
I'll start by creating these
I say const
and then I use some square brackets
and then I say equals
you state
inside this I'll place an array
I'll call this date lat
and then the function to update the
state set lat
next I'll do the same for longitude
so I say const
then I use square brackets
I initialize this with an empty array
I'll call the state lawn
and the function to update the state
settled on next inside the use effect
instead of saying set location I'll say
set let
and then location
Dot
coords
latitude
then I'll do this again for the
longitude
so I'll say settlon
and then I'll pass in location
Dot
coords
longitude
then I can update the API call instead
to use the lat and long pieces of State
additionally I'm going to pass these in
as dependencies inside of the user
Factor array
this means when these change the use
effect will rerun
let's also remove our initial location
piece of State
so now let's add a console log to see if
we can view the weather data
so we'll say if whether
console log
weather
let's save this and see how things are
in the simulator
so now when we look in the console we
can see the weather data has now been
set up and is visible to us
so now we have all the data we need
coming down from the API
next I'm going to do a bit of
refactoring because our app component
has quite a lot of logic inside of it at
this point
so I'm going to extract the current hook
usage into an external file
you can make custom Hooks and then
import them just like when you use a
react hook
the benefit of this is that we can
better encapsulate the logic
in our case we're going to end up with
quite a few things going on so doing
this means our code is much easier to
work with
the only requirement when we do this is
that we name it with something that
starts with use just like when we use
hooks which are from react so to start
I'm going to create a new directory
called hooks
now inside here I'm going to create a
file called use getweather.js
I'll go to this file
and I'll start by creating the function
so I'll say export const
use get weather
as this is a function I need to use an
equal sign
some parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
let's think about what we need to add in
here
we want all the data fetching logic from
the app.js file so let's start by
getting that and then we'll paste it
inside of the function
we're also going to need to get all of
our state because this is dependent upon
by the functionality inside of the hook
so back in the app.js file I'll copy all
the states set up
then I'll go back to the custom hook
file
and I'll paste this at the top of the
use get weather function
lastly we're also going to need some of
the Imports
so let's grab everything from the app.js
file
and then we'll paste it at the top of
the hook file
so we can delete the react native and
the navigation Imports here because
they're not used
lastly at the end of the hook we need to
return inside of an array the pieces of
state that will be needed by our app
component so for us this is the loading
State the error State and the weather
data
the app component itself does not need
the latitude and longitude so we can
keep these scoped only inside of this
hook so at the end of the hook after the
use effect we say return
and then we use an array
and we'll pass in loading
error
and weather
at this point we could actually now use
this hook inside any component we wanted
so this is really helpful if you have
some reusable code which is required by
multiple components as it means you
don't need to duplicate logic
now we're ready to use the hook in our
app component
so if we navigate back to the file we
can start by importing the hook I'm also
going to delete all the unused code now
so now we can use this and we simply
just destructure the values so at the
top of the app file we say const
then we use square brackets
and we set this equal to use getweather
the values to place inside of the array
are loading
error
and weather
so now you can add a console log with
loading
error
and weather
let's save this and test this out in the
simulator
when the simulator runs I now get to see
the loading error and weather data
printed out in the console so we have
proven this works and we now have all
our logic scoped inside of its own hook
so the next thing we're going to do now
is look at wiring up each of our weather
components with the real data
so to start with we need to pass the
weather data to the tabs and then we'll
need to decide which pieces of data are
required by which component
so back in our app.js file let's set a
prop on the tabs called weather
and we'll set this to weather
I'm also going to change the render
order here so if the weather exists we
render the tabs otherwise we'll show the
activity indicator
so I'll place the rendering for the tabs
to be above the rendering for the
activity indicator
and then I'm going to enclose this
inside of an if statement that says if
whether
and
weather.list
then return the navigation container
then I'll remove the condition around
the activity indicator
and just return this
so essentially here we're saying if the
weather exists with the data we'll
render the weather
otherwise show the activity indicator
we'll update this a bit more later to
show an error screen if the error state
is true
so now let's go back to the tabs
component
now inside the tabs component we can
start using this if we take a look at
the data that we get back from the API
we can have a think about what each
component will need
the current weather component only needs
the current weather so we can pass it
the first element of the list array for
the upcoming weather we can pass
everything from the list array
then for the city we can just pass in
the city data
so we're going to do this process
component by component and we'll start
with the current weather component
in order to pass the props to the
component we need to render a callback
to return the element to use for the
screen instead of using the component
prop
so let's start by setting this up we'll
remove the component prop and then we'll
set up the tab screen to return a child
now we can pass in the component so we
use curly braces
a set of parentheses
an arrow
and then the current weather component
on the component we'll pass the props
so we say weather data
and we set this to whether
dot list
and then using square brackets we'll
access the element at the position of
zero
so next we can go to the current weather
component
and we'll add the weather data prop
let's add a console log for this and
check everything is wired up correctly
here
so I'll run the app in the simulator
now I'll check the console brilliant I
now see the data in the console and
we're good to go with wiring up this
component to use this data now so let's
open our current weather component
now we can have a think about what we
need to do in order to get this up and
running properly
the pieces of data I'm going to need for
this component are the temp
feels like
temp Max temp min
and weather
so to start with I'm going to just
structure these from the props so I
start by saying cons
and then I use the set of curly braces
everything except the weather itself I
need to get from Maine so I say Maine
I say temp
feels like
temp Max
and tent men
outside of the curly braces I use a
comma
and I say weather
then I set this equal to weather data
next in order to access the correct
weather type object I'm going to need
access to the weather condition
so I'm going to create a variable to
store this I'll say const weather
condition and I'll set this equal to
weather square brackets 0 Dot
Main
the first thing we're going to do is
update the background color for the
screen so that it's set dynamically from
the weather type utility file
because we want to use a property based
on the data we're going to need to do
this in line so that we have access to
everything we need
so for the style on the safe area view
we'll add in an array
after the wrapper
we'll add a comma
then we'll use inline styles to set the
background color
so we use an object
and inside this we'll set background
color
we'll set this to be weather type
and then we need to pass in the weather
condition so we'll use square brackets
and then inside of the square brackets
we'll Place weather condition
outside of the square brackets we then
want to access the value of the
background color
so we say dot
next we can do a similar thing to
dynamically set the icon
so for the feather element name we'll
add curly braces
and then we'll say weather type
and then we'll use square brackets
inside the square brackets we'll say
weather condition
and then outside of the square brackets
as we want to access the icon we'll say
dot icon
I'm also going to update the color to be
white
next we can update the temperature text
to use the temp value
so we need to add curly braces here as
we're passing in a value
and then inside the curly braces we can
add temp
for the feels like temp we also need to
use curly braces
here I'm going to use a template literal
so inside the curly braces I'll add back
ticks
then I'll say feels like
and I'll interpolate in the feels like
value
the first row text shows the high and
low temperature so I need to update the
message 1 and message two values
I'm going to use template literals here
again
so for the message one I'll use
backticks
then I'll say hi
then a colon
and I'll interpolate in temp Max
for message 2 I'll again use backticks
and I'll say low
colon
and I'll interpolate in temp min
for the next row text we want to show
the weather description which comes from
the data
and then we also want to show the
weather type message
so for message one I'll say whether
and as this is an array I need to use
square brackets and pass in zero
[Music]
then I say dot
description
for the message too instead of passing
in thunderstorm I can remove this string
and instead just pass in the weather
condition
let's save this and see how things look
in the simulator
when the simulator runs I see the
current weather component but we're now
using the values from the weather type
and everything is using the real data
there is one thing though the units are
currently in Kelvin
on the open weather map documentation we
can see this is the default
on our app we want to use metric so we
need to add this to the API call
if we go back to the use get weather
hook we can append this to the API call
we use the and symbol
and then we say units
equals
metric
now if we reload the simulator we can
see the new values
this screen will now look different
every time the weather type changes
so that is our current weather component
updated for now with the data next we
can move on to updating the upcoming
weather component let's go back to our
tabs and set this up
so back in the tabs component we'll
remove the component prop and then set
up the tab screen to return a child
then we can pass in the component
so we use curly braces
and then a set of parentheses
an arrow
and then the upcoming weather component
next on the component I'll say weather
data
and I'll pass in whether
dot list
this means we have access to all the
upcoming data
so next I'll go back to the upcoming
weather component
and I'll pass in weather data to the
component
I'm going to start by removing all the
dummy data we added
additionally I'm going to remove the
title for the component
so I can also now remove the text from
the Imports
next in the data proper the flat list
I'll pass in weather data
the values for the list item inside of
render item are already set up from the
dummy data so now we can go straight to
the list component and see what we need
to update
in this component we also have all the
props set up from the dummy data but we
need to do some refinements here
I'm going to start by updating the icon
to use the icon from the weather type
dynamically
so to start I need to import the file
so I say import
then I use curly braces
and inside the curly braces I add
weather type
and I'll import this from utilities
slash weather type
then for the feather icon name I'll
remove the string some
and I'll say weather type
square brackets
our passing condition into the square
brackets
and then I'll say dot icon
because space is limited for the list
item I'm then going to change the Min
and Max temperature to be all in one
line
and I'm also going to round these values
so to start I'll delete the text with
Max
then I'll use a template literal and
interpolate in
math
Dot
round
and I'll pass in min
then I'll interpolate in
math
Dot
round
and I'll pass in Max
I'll separate these with a slash
also we want to show the degree symbol
on each of these values on a Mac I can
do this with option shift 8.
on a Windows this is Alt 0176
next we'll look at formatting the date
text and I'm going to use a library to
help us with this called moment.js
moment.js helps us pass and format any
data related to time and dates
it's a really useful library to know
about because it provides a lot of
options for how to display what can
sometimes be quite complicated data to
the user
let's start by installing it
in the terminal I need to type npm
install
ment dash dash save
we're going to split the date text into
two sections one that shows the day and
one that shows the time
so back in the component let's add
another piece of text under the one that
currently shows DT text
also to display these we're going to
want these to be split onto two lines
so we'll wrap these inside of a view
and then we'll set some Styles here
we'll just call these date text wrapper
inside the style sheet let's add this
and then we can set Flex Direction
to column
NAD format value we need to start by
importing moment
so at the top of the file we say import
moment from moment
so let's have a quick look at the
documentation
on the first line we want to show the
day so we can do this by passing in d d
we then want to show the time on the
next line and we can do this by passing
in H
double m
double s
let's go back to our component and set
this up
so for the piece of text we want to show
the name inside of the curly braces we
say moment and then pass in DT txt then
we say dot format
and we pass in the string
DD
in the second piece of text we say
moment
and again pass in DT txt
then we say dot format
and this time we pass in H
colon
mm
SS
and Then followed by a space followed by
a
so the a will show the AM or PM
let's save all of this and see how this
component now looks in the simulator
when the simulator runs we now see all
of our list data showing on the screen
with the new layout improvements
so next we need to go back to our tabs
component and move on to wiring up our
city screen
so back in the tabs component we'll
remove the component prop
and then we'll set up the tab screen to
return a child
next we can pass in the component
so we use curly braces
a set of parentheses
an arrow
and then component
now we can pass in the data
so we say weather data
and we pass in whether
Dot
City
now let's go back to our component
let's start by setting the prop in the
parameters
and then we can destructure out the
values we're going to need so I say
const
then I use some curly braces
and I set this equal to weather data
inside the curly braces I'll add name
country
population
sunrise
and sunset
the first value we're going to update is
the city name
so I can remove London
and I'll add some curly braces
inside the curly braces
I'll add name
I can now do the same for Country so I
remove UK
and then I add some curly braces
inside the curly braces I'll add country
next I can update the first icon text
body text value
I'm going to use a template literal here
so I'll remove 8000
then I'll use some back ticks
then I'll say population
colon
and I'll interpolating population
I can then move on to updating the
second icon text
I'm going to use moment again here to
help us with our formatting
so I'll import moment from moment at the
top of the file
now back in the body text I will say
moment
and I'll pass in Sunrise
then I'll say dot
format
and pass in h colon mm
colon SS
and then a space
and a
then for the last icon text body text
value I'm also going to use moment again
so this time I say moment
and I'll pass in Sunset
then I use a DOT
and I say format
inside format I pass in H
colon
mm
SS
then a space
and a
let's save this and see how it looks in
the simulator
everything for the screen looks good and
this has now also been updated to use
the data from the API
so that's all our existing screens set
up to use the data
there's just a couple of minor fixes I
want to do
I want to add the degree symbol to the
current weather component
so let's go back to that component now
in the first two pieces of text I'll add
the degree symbol here
I also want to add a space between the
high and low text
so on the message one prop here I'm just
going to add a space at the end
so now we have these refinements done
let's move on to creating an error
screen for the application
inside the components directory I'm
going to create a component called error
item
now inside this component we can set it
up just like a standard component
so I'll import react from react
then our import View
text
and style sheet
from react native
I'm also going to import feather
from at Expo icons
so now we can declare the component
I say const
error item
equals
then I use a set of parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
I'll make sure the component is exported
so at the bottom of the file I say
export default
error item
before the export I also need to set up
the style sheet
so I say const styles
equals
stylesheet
Dot
create
and I'll pass in an object here
inside the component I'll save return
and then I'll add a view
and some text
inside the text I'll pass in the message
sorry something went wrong
next I'm going to add a feather icon
so I'll say feather
and then I'll set name
to frown
size
to 100
and color
to White
so let's set up the styles
on The View I'll say Style
equals
styles
Dot
container
on the text I'll say Style
equals
styles
Dot
error message
then inside the style sheet our set
container
and I'll say Flex
of one
background color
of red
justify content
of Center
and align items
and then for the text
I'll say font size
of 30
color
of white
margin horizontal
of 10
and text align
up Center
now let's test this out
in the app.js file we can start by
importing error item from components
error item
next in the render with the activity
indicator we can use a conditional and
say if loading
then return the activity indicator
otherwise
return the error item
to test this I'm going to go to the use
get weather hook
at the bottom of the hook where we
return the values I'll say true for the
error
and I'll add an empty array for the
weather
this just means we now have the state
set up in order to test out our error
item
so let's save this and see how it looks
in the simulator
when the simulator runs I see the error
screen that the user would see if
something went wrong when the location
and weather are being set
let's go back to our hook file and
revert the changes we just made so we
set the error and weather back in the
values returned by the hook
so now let's go through our app screen
by screen and check if there's any other
refactoring we need to do
when I look at the current weather
screen I can see we need to add the
degree symbol to the initial temperature
value
I also want to slightly decrease the
font size in the description and message
so let's do that now
back in the component I'll add the
degree symbol to the temperature
then in the style sheet I'm going to
remove the pink background color as this
is now not needed
then I'm going to set the description
font size to be 43.
and the message font size to be 25.
I'm lastly going to add optional
chaining in the places that we are
accessing nested object properties this
means undefined will be returned if one
of the properties does not exist instead
of an error
next let's take a look at the upcoming
weather screen
as we're using white text I think the
background color of the list items is
slightly light so let's update that
let's go back to the list item component
I'm going to set item background color
to the Indian red
this is all one word and all lower case
lastly I'll add optional chaining where
we're using the weather type
everything looks a bit better in the
simulator now so let's take a look at
the city screen
everything on this screen now looks good
to go
so we're ready to move on to making the
final touches to our application
the last thing I want to do on our app
is adjust the app component very
slightly
I want to change the conditional to show
the error item if the error state is
true and then otherwise show the loading
screen
this just ensures that the user really
does only see the error screen when
there is an error
so I'll say if error
then show error item
otherwise
show the activity indicator
so that is everything done and our app
is now complete
before I wrap up this course there's a
couple of last topics I'd like to
introduce you to but you can consider
this as bonus material
the first one of these topics is the
context API
you may have noticed when I implemented
the tab screens as children that the
documentation said that it advised you
use the context API
the reason I did not do this is because
we only have three core screens on the
app
however if you're in a position where
you're passing the data around a lot of
components who are very far away in the
component tree and also perhaps that the
state is complex then the context API is
very handy to know about
it's also really useful if you have some
global data which is needed throughout
the application such as a user's name or
some theming for the application
by using the context API all the logic
can become centralized
it's not specifically the right or wrong
approach it very much depends on your
use case and it becomes a slightly
different way of handling your data
instead of props so you can share
anything through the context and once we
share the data the component can ask the
context for the bits of data it needs
it's important not to overuse context
and definitely don't think of it as a
replacement props but it's an approach
that it's worth knowing about for when
you need to access specific pieces of
global data throughout the application
the documentation about context is here
but essentially there are three steps to
creating context
you need to start by importing the
context
then you would Define your context so if
you had a rim context you'd say const
room context and you'd set this equal to
create context
then you wrap the context around your
components and at this point your
components can access the context
the last couple of topics I wanted to
cover are UI based topics
we haven't had the need in our
application to create a button although
we have seen how the react native button
component works
did you notice how this didn't really
look like a button that you might have
expected another common task when you're
developing applications that you may
encounter is creating custom buttons
react native has a set of touchable
components which help us with this
if we take a look at touchable opacity
we can see that it's a wrapper for
responding to touches
alternatively we have touchable without
feedback but this doesn't give us a
visual response so this is likely not
what you want to use when you're
creating a button
in the demonstration directory that I
created earlier I'm going to go ahead
and Implement a button just so that
you're familiar with how to achieve this
and then I'll start by setting up the
component so I'll import react from
react then I'll import View
touchable opacity
and text
from react native
next I'll set up the component
so I say const
R button
equals
and then a set of parentheses
an arrow
and some curly braces
I'll then export the component
so I just say export default
R button
next I'll set up the style sheet
so I say const styles
equals
style sheet
Dot
create
into this I pass in an object
so next in the component I say return
and then I'm going to use touchable
opacity
and inside this some text
for the text I'll just say hello
then on the TouchPal opacity we pass in
on press
and we'll set some Styles so we say
style equals
styles
Dot
container
would also set some styles for the text
so I say style equals
styles
Dot
button text
in the style sheet I'll add these Styles
so I'll start with the container
I set elevation
to eight
this sets the elevation of the item on
Android only
next I say background color
of blue
border radius
and I'll set padding
to five
then for the button text I'll set font
size
to 15.
color
to White
and align self
to Center
then on the touchable opacity we set an
on-press prop so let's set this up
we use this to Define what we want to
happen when the user presses the button
so I'll set up an arrow function called
on press
and inside this I'll add a contour log
which just prints out press
to test this out let's go to the app
component
I'll comment out the navigation
container render
and then I'm going to import the button
so I say import R button
from demonstration R button
then I'll add this to the render before
the activity indicator
Let's test this out in the simulator
when the simulator runs I get to see the
button if I open the console I can see
the Press is printed out every time that
I press the button
I strongly advise you spend some time
playing about with all the core
components in react native as there's a
lot you can achieve you can look at
modals for alerts text input for text
input fields and the switch component
acts like a toggle